rude I'm gonna call Benson hold on wait
hold on let me call I'm gonna call
Benton so that he can pull his weight
and help me do ads okay hello where's my
article furniture yes I need I'm trying
to put together my outdoor display I
need it what did I order I know but
didn't I order a dining set or did we
not get that yet did you know they have
weather-resistant dining sets loungers
which i need more of especially given
the fact that no one's allowed to come
over right now but I need them for me
and my dogs and I also have two new
ducks and a rabbit so we need the
lounger the sofa and all of the outdoor
furniture because nature's back and I
want that but I have a bobcat too I feel
like we should get one of the loungers
for the Bobcat to sit on perch okay so
you know that I hate reading ads for
Batum and sounding corny and like I'm
just phoning it in and you're literally
phoning it in so why don't you describe
article furniture because we're already
fans of this company in his car he's not
reading add coffee
he's just winging it see this is how
much we love this company we do not need
any I describe it as having sweida isn't
it Swedish Dutch influences I'm not like
a big I'm not good at describing
architecture but I know classy when I
see it I know sexy when I see it it's
the perfect combination of rustic and
sensual and everything matches that's
the other thing I like about it you
don't have to be like have an eye you
don't have to be like an interior
decorator you can just like order ten
things and they all just go with each
other so you look like you
have better taste than you do as long as
you just order all article furniture I
also every time I go onto the website I
think that there's some kind of mistake
because everything actually is like
reasonably priced and I'm so used to
furniture just being like cartoonishly
expensive for no apparent reason and I
can't pay a lot of money for furniture
my dogs get on my furniture I'm not
gonna pay two thousand dollars for
freaking carpet it's not happening so
the good news about article is that you
save 30 percent over traditional retail
retail as you would say retail prices
retool retail prices article is able to
keep their prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you
know showrooms no sales people no
contracting Korona in a sales room and
no retail markups it's fast affordable
shipping is available across the USA in
Canada and is free and orders over nine
hundred and ninety nine dollars all in
stock items are delivered in two weeks
or less article is offering our
listeners $50 off your first purchase
for $100 or more go to article comm
slash Whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied to checkout also
take pictures of your article furniture
and tag us because I want to see what
you're doing with your article furniture
I'm killing it over here making cozy
nooks and welcoming warm moments and
spaces for when people are allowed to
come over again but in the mean time and
makes for a great place to shoot content
with all my new stuff article is
offering our listeners $50 off your
first purchase of $100 or more go to
article dot-com slash Whitney if you
want your house to look like mine chic
hot sex a rustic the discount will be
automatically applied at check up that's
article dot-com slash Whitney to get $50
off your first purchase of $100 or more
what a steal
[Music]
okay are we ready by the way we can cut
anything out later sure you want
obviously never once done that B have
you not no no you never I'm always like
go for it let's see let's see what
happens you've never gone on a podcast
and later been like I shoulda said that
oh yeah I've done that but I've never
been but I'd like let the dice fall
where they may like the point of being
community enough to worry about that
shit
yeah they talkin to New York Times I
told my manager and she was like I told
him no comment what did you say and I
was like we'll find out next week like I
don't know okay I always start the
podcast with asking the guests if we're
friends are we friends of course yeah
like are we good friends I mean I don't
know that that much about you but we're
good friends like we're good comedy
friends yes in that we started together
and so I was like the thing about this
on the way over here that like we
started together and we had a bond right
away even though we didn't talk that
much and that I felt like you and I were
both much better than we should have
been at the beginning do you know what I
mean like even we were at open mics like
we were the best at the open mics that
we like kind of just like noticed each
other and we're like okay like you're
just you gravitate toward the people who
are also good cuz you see so many people
who are hopeless and people that are
working hard too yes working hard have
different stuff and are just like trying
new things not doing the same thing that
bombs and then I felt like we solidified
our friendship where I was like friends
for life after the roast of Donald Trump
yes when I sat next to you and you and I
was like nervous this is my big break
and he was so kind to me and you could
have been like you know like it's like
what I love Jeff Ross he's like a
brother to me yeah but when you're
getting ready for a roast it's like
where's Ross performing cuz I'm gonna go
in the other side of town I don't want
him to see my jokes but with you you was
like very like we're like we're in this
together like we're friends what do you
need to know let me give you a piece of
advice that I was like oh like you're
not trying to sabotage me to make
yourself look better that after that I
was like I love Whitney forever
there's nothing you could do that would
that would lower our friendship now
that's so cool
I always just because I feel like some
of these podcasts we go on each other's
pockets never like pretends they're like
besties and I just like the audience to
hear from the other person not from me
like you know when you hear you go in a
podcast some was like so anyway this
girl's a really good friend of mine I'm
like easy you can tell when I don't like
agree with like the person we'll try it
I believe we've been great friends
forever right and I'm just like like
once Joe Rogan told me that like Ari
Shaffir is a great comic and then we
just stared at each other for a like 15
minutes
I don't know what you expect me to do
now but I'm gonna I like so here's my
deal with you when I first met you I
think I was very intimidated by you I'm
sure people tell you that alone because
I had no ability to tolerate silence
from another person it just it was like
a Rorschach test like you're very much a
Rorschach test to me if people are like
Anthony like me I'm like you hate
yourself and if people like loved that
guy I'm like okay yeah you're
emotionally stable because I feel like
you really probably bring out people's
nasty inner monologue with how little
and you give in a fake way yes like it's
hard for me to be fake and I have a
resting bitch face which like which I
don't mind people are like it's also
very handsome thank you you're very
handsome thank you but I'm like I've
heard like my eye contact is intense
it's very nice like Bobby Kelly once
told me that circa we're at the Comedy
Cellar table and he's like you look like
you just thought of the worst insult you
say to me and you're just choosing not
to say it but I was like I don't mind
this eye God I'm not like I'm not gonna
like disabuse you of that yeah well you
always make me realize how fake most
people are because I'm like Anthony got
a dick everyone else is just fake and
phony you're just like what's up yeah I
know I was like is he mad no everyone
else was just bullshit people will be
like you're so nice and I'm like I'm not
that nice I'm just way nicer than you
think I'm gonna be you know and so when
I first met you I think
I was very confused by you because I at
the I mean we must have what 22 23 23
yeah I didn't know what to do with male
attention like I only knew how to like
flirt or try to manipulate or use sex as
power or entrench and you were very like
you could be friends with women you know
you had like girlfriends that were you
know and you were just like hey you just
were respectful and platonic and I just
didn't ever do that yeah is this a game
what is it I've heard that from a lot of
female comics that like you felt like
you treat people like women you treat
women like yeah I just had a lot of
sisters like I just this is how I talk
to women that I never thought like other
the fucking this bitch over here like
that's why I hated the Comedy Store for
so long because everyone there were just
like such jerks to women like a woman
walked by in the hallway and they would
be there with all these comments and I
was like what are you guys doing like
work on your act like what what is this
place that I just wanted nothing to do
with it see this is you're making me
realize when I first met you you were so
nice and fair like you treated men
female comics and male comics equally
and I think I was I assumed you were
flirting but you're actually just being
nice mhm
in respectful I get that a lot and I
understand so well he was just so nice
to me I mean we I mean and then but then
what then nothing nothing would happen I
was like oh that was weird I guess he's
just mine playing with my head is that a
mind game it was like no it's just
someone being respectful yeah I didn't
know I know that was back that I just
like comedians and I treat them all the
same yes you know like if you're a comic
I don't care if you're male or female
like we have a bond that we can almost
talk in a shorthand so traffic confuses
some people like I always say I'm closer
to a comedian I've never met than the
person I'm in a relationship with mm-hmm
which is very confused which i think is
it's hard I think for people that we get
in intimate relationships with because
there's always gonna be a bunch of
strangers that are closer to me than you
will ever be yes and I also found that a
lot of female comics would you're
younger female comics would flirt for no
reason like flirt to network and some
people would like fall for that and I
just software I'm like I know what
you're doing and I'm just going to like
stand here and like I'm like a brick
wall I'm like I'm not
I'm not going to even reciprocate this
but I'm like I'm just kind of watching
you flail yeah it happened a lot that I
just never engaged but I also wasn't
like I think she likes me it's like
that's just what they're doing to
childhood I think the longest time it
was hard to negotiate like okay I have
this urge to make strangers love me and
technically I'm sitting around a bunch
of comics like I need to turn it off
when I'm with comics especially male
comedians but the second they call my
name up I have to turn it right on see
people people hated me so much really in
the beginning yeah like imagine like
remember me at like 23 yeah what I mean
like just like a look at like just like
a pretty little boy is you walk in slow
motion mm-hmm I think a lot of people
don't know that about you like you're
like one of the girls from Baywatch
running and it everything stops like
when you walk into a room you're very
handsome the eyes and the hair and the
whole thing and you're Anthony now or
whatever but you also just walk so slow
that it's it's very disarming and it's a
very like silverback alpha thing to do
even though I don't think you're doing
it on purpose no it's just the way I
walk and there's no desperation
emanating from you and I think that when
someone's emanating like a need or a
desperation it's easy to lock into that
frequency and you just have this like
bulletproof orb around you that's just
like I'm full I get my internal needs
met internally don't need anything from
anyone and I think it's just like fuck
that guy he doesn't need anything from
me and part of that is just like
preparing for the stage you know being
on stage was so like was just like the
adrenaline came that I was like I'm
gonna prepare for this sick before I
even walk in the room interesting I was
like already getting ready to get on
stage afterwards you would find me much
more chatty you know then I would be
beforehand before and I'm just like
uh-huh yeah but then after the show it's
like yeah what's up like what's what's
going on a drink you know this was also
around the time where that book came out
called the game where it was like guys
would nag women like they would what was
it you would say something was wrong
with their face or something was a big
like your nose is kind of big maybe like
I need this guy to like me yeah that's
this is how guys that couldn't get laid
would insults pretty girl
in order to fuck with them because
they're used to just getting you know an
adult rated attention in compliments
they'd say like one of your ears is
bigger than the other or whatever I love
that book so that was funny you know so
hilarious to read but I had Suk's I was
like I was on the road at the time and I
had to put duct tape over the cover
because it looked like a Bible and I was
like I can't be reading this as if I'm
like like mmm I got a highlight that it
was like I'm reading this as I could
joke yeah yeah I can't have people see
me reading it and so it's interesting
because I feel like I hope this isn't
come off the wrong way probably well
like you have not changed in terms of
your demeanor since I felt like you've
all like to me now looking back I'm like
you were always so emotionally healthy I
assumed everybody was a mess in their
20s like I just don't see you having
been a mess in your 20s a little bit of
one yeah a little bit of one yeah I mean
I was like a big I was like a bigger
drinker
I just took comedy so seriously yes and
I saw people who didn't like I was very
much like I looked for what do you call
it
what do you call like someone who's an
example of what not to do a cautionary
tale okay I would say name and I realize
I shouldn't I saw so many cautionary
tales that it was just like don't be
like that don't be like that like I
looked for idols people I could like
like oh I want I want to take this thing
from that person this thing from that
person but I saw a lot of things not to
do ya know not to do that yeah I feel
like we started a time where we saw a
lot of people that should have gone
further and their decisions in their
personal life thwarted that I think you
and I both treated comedy like it was a
job and not a party no crap we can party
later but when I'm gonna fucking open
mic yep like this is not a party I want
to get through this I mean and we were
doing I think a lot of people don't
understand like I mean I was driving a
Culver City at 5:00 p.m. to put my name
in a bucket to go up at 6 p.m. for three
minutes I mean I remember the first time
I saw you I am I'm sure we saw each
other at M bar like a lot like socially
but it was a taste like a sushi
restaurant and there was a Tigerlily
it wasn't Tiger Lily on Vermont it was
like it was like a
block I mean it was like a wooden
platform we had to step up on and it was
like a Tuesday night show it was like at
once a month on a Tuesday night whatever
just silly myspace show whatever it was
and I remember seeing you get up and it
was um like a wooden box that was kind
of uneven and everyone would get up
Emilio the books and make some dumb drug
and you just got up didn't really shake
for you like you were not interested in
the box being a part of your act like
you were not letting the room be a joke
you were the only person that didn't
spend the first three minutes making fun
of the restaurant you just like had your
shit like did your shit and like that
was that yeah like I'm not doing crowd
work I'm not gonna waste any of my time
up here and I was like oh Jesus he's not
joking yeah who wants to crowd work at
an open mic it's like that just means
you don't have the material it's like
I'm trying these jokes out yeah to find
out what's going to work for the next
like real show and I just it was very
clear you were just like wasting no time
mm-hmm you know but it's interesting
because I also I think in the beginning
I would get very insecure around you
because I couldn't find a way in like I
realize when not so not so much because
I know that much about you it's more
that I knew how looking back now I know
how sick someone was in their 20's based
on how close I was able to get to them
to not I mean so the craziest people
would entrench with me and have like you
know crazy addictive affairs and bender
and whatever like I just couldn't get
close to you it was just it's just so
interesting that there was just there's
like no way in and I look back and I
just I think in the beginning I thought
like oh he must be so dark he must be so
mean he might and now I look back and I
was like no I think you were actually
the healthiest person in the room it
just took it took me a long time to make
comedian friends mm-hmm you know I I got
into comedy like part of it was to
become friends with comedians I love
comedians and I would like you know like
you're on stage and you introduce the
next comic yeah you guys shake hands or
you used to yeah yeah
and then you would whisper something in
the person's ear they'd like laugh for a
second and walk off I wouldn't didn't
know what they were saying and that's
one of the reasons I got into comedy and
when I started people just avoided me
like I was I looked like a pretty rich
kid even though I had no money I do
people were just like avoided me like I
was like I was like I was not going to
be around very long it's almost like the
new guys get to war and it's like
you're probably get killed I don't want
to get to know you and so it took a long
time until I became accepted mm-hmm you
know I still kind of feel like I'm a
little bit on the outside looking in
with a lot of the comedy community
really cuz I'm not like I'm a piece of
shit like I'm not self-deprecating ever
mm-hmm and a lot of people are that's is
that a choice is that a conscious choice
I think it's partly organic and partly a
choice like I like being so dark mm-hmm
was partly a choice and partly organic
like my whole childhood I would they
were like that's too dark like you're
like you're obsessed with these dark
things and I was like why is that a
problem the greatest philosophers of all
time have been obsessed with death yeah
why is it weird that I am and it made me
feel bad about it that I was like okay
like let me lean into that yeah and not
being self-deprecating I just saw so
many people who were and it seemed hard
I hated like attractive people who were
like can't find a girlfriend you like
I'm like I'm not doing that
yeah and I mean it was so many people
did it and it just seemed funnier to me
not yeah well the jokes in the surprise
is the thing everybody's not doing when
you come out here like this jokes about
to blow your mind you're like oh shit
that's just so funny cuz everyone's like
I hope you like this joke you know it's
just the opposite of what everyone was
doing for so long I used to open for
people like I open for like Doug Benson
Brian Cox I mean Sarah Silverman and I
would open with I would walk out and I
would go I don't know who your favorite
comedian is but you're about to trade up
and everyone is like what the who the
fuck is this this guy's the opener like
I treated it like I was the headliner
and afters who were like goddamn like
that's a good life I also it took me so
long to realize that people that are
dark ostensibly whatever that even means
those in a weird way like as I get to
know you better
no weird way the lightest people yes
right because you get it out it's the
people that are seeing the sunniest and
ostensibly seen the happiest those are
the motherfuckers you got to worry about
it's like you can't be that happy I'll
to no I don't believe it shoes gonna
drop the Damocles sword is gonna fall
yeah and so that's part of the reason
that I like now that I sort of it's like
worked enough on myself to be able to
see things clearly and not be threatened
by healthy secure people that I trust
you I think more than I would trust the
average person because you're just like
openly dark I'm like oh there's no
secrets here they're all out yeah and I
thought I also thought like in the begin
like I'm in the law I'm in it for the
long haul yeah like what is how can my
act play at 23 and still play at 43 yeah
you know and that you see some comics
who like do like the college thing and
it's like when you get in your 30s like
it gets sad and it's like it's like
weird to watch that I wanted something
that would be able to age age gracefully
let me also admit to you that I it's
interesting I used to kind of think that
if you are guy's favorite comedian it
was a red flag
I saw but now it's literally if you're
not I'm like you don't get it I saw a
tweet Sam was like oh like I'm like
looking at tinder like oh you like dark
humor does that mean you think Anthony
Jeselnik is funny or that you hate women
you don't I mean cuz some people think
that dark is like synonymous with
misogyny I'll be like so racial slurs
how often do you use them and I'm like I
don't like what do you that I put you're
dark and I'm like yeah I'm dark darks
about death it's not about racism huh
you can be a feminist and be dark right
you know that people didn't get that
yeah I mean it's interesting I do feel
like I get that as well like and maybe
it's cuz I was on the roasts or you know
whatever it is it's people also like I
got that with self-deprecation because
what we did on the roasts and I laugh
when people call me a cunt and ugly and
all that it gave people permission to
just be like hey cunt like in the
airport I'd be like no not the same
thing
oh yeah not the same thing I get all the
time I get cuz like the jokes about us
like it's different because like for a
woman it's like you're gonna be the
whore they're gonna call you ugly but
for guys like there wasn't that much
they could say you know you're
impossible to write jokes about what are
the jokes I wrote about you I won like
the one joke that people repeat to me
all the time is Patrice O'Neal being
like go get me a turkey leg you fucking
nothing you look like a medieval like a
medieval times waiter and I laughed but
I like truly didn't get it I was like
what a medical times waiters look like I
don't know if anyone but Patrice said it
I wouldn't think I mean I laughed at
time but people say it to me and I'm
like what do you want from me right now
yeah like I've heard that joke but when
Patrice said it to me I laughed and it
was like cool
but now when you're saying it back to me
like I'm with Jeff Ross and people come
up and insult him all the time with old
insults and he's very pleasant about it
but I thought like for people like you
and Lampanelli like I was like that must
suck so much to have like it's like I
want to talk about the roasts because
you and I both just did three and then
got the fuck out and I think like they
both made it I think they started our
careers for sure yes but then it was
like alright I'm done with these and I
couldn't imagine what would bring me
back
well it's interesting cuz I wanted to
bring this up but because what I
remember one of my favorite things I've
ever seen on a roast was you on the
Trump roast and just coming up just
killing killing killing killing and then
you Brutus savage right the best and
then you at Lisa Lampanelli you're cool
like one of my favorite ROS moments
which is such a comedian's favorite joke
yes I have never made fun of a female of
a woman's appearance on a roast except
for once once I did it like I've always
been there for Marlee Matlin because I
thought it was so funny
Itzik right elected and it was right
before I did the Lampanelli you're cool
yeah yeah and I saw I was like I've got
to gear up to make limp and I like yes
yes and I found that afterwards she was
like I saw a different therapist just
for you like when I found out you were
gonna be in the roast I looked you up
and I was like this guy's such an
asshole he's gonna kill nine finale yeah
and then afterwards was just like so
happy
her husband was like thank you so much
and I was like what do you mean I was
just trying to be funny I know after
that roast we went up to her room by
that time I was friends with Lisa
Lampanelli you know Lisa Lampanelli for
those of you that that don't know I'd be
surprised but was you know queen of the
roast for you know the longest time and
then when we started doing them we were
like sort of the kids and I just thought
of her as the toughest most steel bald
yes you know she's Lisa Lampanelli and
she's the biggest laughs and then she
comes out and just destroys everyone at
the end after they've destroyed her I
mean she closed most of the rows for a
while which is like kind of like the
spot you get when you're the and she
closed back before they used to
cross-reference jokes
you know what I mean like Oh at the end
they would be like everyone turned your
jokes
and they would come to you and be like
Whitney actually someone who's going
before you has this joke I'm telling
this because I'd want to hear that
basically means like before you'd have
to show the producers and the writers
your jokes so that no one repeated jokes
because when I when I did the Joan
Rivers roast my first roast no one we
didn't do that and I just sat there as
other comedians went up and just
basically did similar premises oh
there's an eight greg Giraldo did a
fucking brilliant AIDS quilt joke mine
you know I have to cut cut my you're
just sitting there cutting jokes while
you're shooting you work so hard on
crafting this sort of perfect set and
then people start biting all the premise
yeah so Lampanelli going last psych like
it was like dude for the work of anybody
else last is like the scariest spot
because you know every reference is
gonna be done especially if there's
something in the zeitgeist topical OJ or
you know something someone dies or
there's some you know you know like
everyone's gonna try to get to that a
911 joke everyone's gonna try to do that
reference first yeah yeah so you and I
okay we're gonna talk about the rest in
a second I also I feel like I was
annoyed that we weren't closer friends
until the roast like I was a little bit
like how come like I feel like we should
be friends
right we covered that and then we get to
the roasts and you had written on a
roast before though yes I wrote for
Hasselhoff okay that's right and I was
on I was on Hasselhoff okay I remember
that I remember that and then how did
you get the job on the roasts they like
a little halfway through the Hasselhoff
thing they were like maybe we'll bring
in Anthony because I was like I was
killing it like I came in yes and the
jokes they were like loving my jokes and
Comedy Central he liked me Liz Porter
yes in charge of it was like maybe
should be Anthony yeah and the Jeff Ross
said I've heard this later he was like
Anthony's been giving away his best
stuff for two weeks like let's let put
him on the next one and not put him on
this one
hmm and I was okay with that but so they
had me do won't remember I had to do
warm up for the Hasselhoff roast made me
walk out while the dais was out there
Pam Anderson is not having me and
they're cutting to her reaction shot
remember when she tried to get up after
my set and leave oh it was so IRA being
in the writers room and all the jokes
about how ugly she is now and I'm like
guys I don't think she's ugly and then
she showed up and looked smoking-hot
fucking gorgeous if every job just
bombed and people just kept on doing she
came up to me right before the roasts
and went you know my kids are gonna be
watching this and I was like no no no
you're I know what you're doing I'm not
gonna let you do it dude I'm I don't
have as much money as you I have to kill
on this I'm sorry everyone I did the
Roseanne roast it was all older women
and before the roast they all like come
in like fucking Pixies another Anthony
you're so handsome we love you so much
and then after the roast I didn't say
weird to me you know it's like that try
to like butter me up and it's like I've
already written the joke oh yeah no no
it's making me feel like we're closer so
I can make more fun of you I can't
soften this can do this yeah so yeah so
the Hasselhoff roast is kind of a blur
to me I remember that being I the
problem with the roast is like I think
for women it's sort of like the Oscars
of comedy and your instinct is like to
dress up like a whore and that's what I
feel like for the has Laura's I don't
know why I thought like I if I just look
good enough they won't call me ugly they
pick it wait like remember writing for
Hasselhoff and they're like it's all
these gay jokes about Hulk Hogan and I'm
a there ever been a room and they're
like nobody's a wrestler so we gotta
have the gay guy and he's got that yeah
yeah it's like you gotta begin you got
the fat guy you gotta have the whore and
I was like why why not my jokes about
the person and they were just they got
so lazy that's why the roast would like
it didn't never upset me if you told a
joke about me Lampanelli
Ross those were it was like an honor
yeah Patrice was an honor but when
anybody else anybody else I could just
picture 12 fat fucking bitter comedy
writers who were jealous of me sitting
there thinking of the worst things they
could say so those jokes just it didn't
hurt me but it pissed me off yeah it was
just a little bit like at least don't be
sloppy if you're gonna insult me at
least put some thought into it like the
last roast I did everyone called me a
flat-out
rapist like flat-out like Anthony's of
rapists and I was like like that's
that's like that's my thing yeah it was
they're too lazy to think of something
else but it's also we've been in those
writers rooms where it's just kind of
like okay he's really funny his
is great you can't really knock him for
you know like having movies mom or his
not being funny you can't say I mean
that's like kind of what happened with
Sarah Silverman on was it James Franco
or there was somewhere they were calling
her old because it was just like you
can't say she does have a great career
you can't say she's not funny you can't
say that she's failed in television so I
was like well she's 42 so I guess we're
gonna call her old like yeah you have to
have some kind of well to go to like you
know and it does get cheap and it gets
sloppy in it you know and you know
you've been there we're on the roasts
like people drop out three days before
of course because they get scared or
they watch a roast and they see what the
fuck it's about and they panic you know
so a lot of times you're writing those
cheap jokes like at the last minute like
I remember we did a bunch of jokes was
this for I thinks at the Saget roast
when I was a writer on the Saget roast
we wrote a bunch of jokes for Artie
Lange and you know it's he's fat and
he's the and he's fat fat fat everything
was fat Joker so fat years about and
then he had an incident and couldn't
make it and so we're just like
frantically calling anyone that could
fit the fat jokes like Patrice Louie
Anderson and you just go down the line
of Ralphie May whoever and then Jeff
Garlin said yes and he's not that fat
like I mean it was like the jokes which
is way too brutal I mean it was I think
Cloris Leachman was like why is there a
beanbag chair on the stage
oh that's Jeff Garlin yes like too far
will bother me too was it like if it you
would think of a joke bombed in the room
like if we just stand up and we're doing
a special a joke bomb you don't just
sweeten it and move on yeah you cut that
joke out that's what I'm the roast a
joke could eat it yeah and then they cut
not only they like cut to the audience
someone laughing hysterically and it
makes it like it was the biggest psych
lineup tonight and you're like why did
you just fuck me like this like this is
not the worst yeah quite frankly yeah
and I know it's it's like it's a
television show but it was it like in me
after three I was like I'm done
and then yeah I remember after the Trump
roast uh going upstairs it was in New
York that you were normally in LA that
one was in New York and they were like
these stairs and it's like this weird
hotel like there's like a weird set up
it was like a ballroom instead of like a
soundstage I remember going upstairs in
hearing
like what's going on it was Lisa
Lampanelli was crying and I was just
like I don't I don't feel good about
this like I this is and then went in and
then this was her ritual she would go
and she'd take all these punches and
they'd call her fat and they'd make the
black dick jokes and you're the whatever
and then she would laugh and you know
put on a brave face and then just cry
and be much and I just was like it blew
my mind that someone had to go through
that and it just it like broke my heart
I always assumed that it's not like what
they say it's that you know you're gonna
be hearing it for a long time you know
you know that people your fans are even
gonna be like like you fat bitch people
have so she's like oh this is like what
it's gonna this is my image now yes yeah
and she's married to a white guy it was
also just like an outdated sort of joke
and a button sort of um yeah and it was
interesting and I remember like the
first roast I did not get my feelings
hurt I was so grateful to be there I was
such a greg Giraldo fan to just even
meet Greg Dahl it was a big deal for me
he had one of my favorite jokes actually
which was a you two are very similar to
me and how like surprising your turns
are he just went Whitney Cummings is
here for some reason I just kept going
he was one of the reasons I got out as I
saw how much more miserable he got as he
just like almost feel like he had to
keep doing it yeah and he didn't enjoy
them like he enjoyed him in the
beginning and then was just like going
through the motions and I was like this
looks unpleasant I think like Jeff Ross
like loves it but like loves it he's
like and he never dips it's always just
like yeah he's running that steady
marathon people like it's an honor but
keep stood by him for the rest of the
year do you not I mean it's just like
something that he likes to do all the
time as part of his thing I mean I also
just like the pry I can't really divorce
the being on the roast from the process
of making the roast it's so it was just
too stressful for me it was like the
whole deal with comedy for me is that
the part of reason I love it so much is
I don't feel competitive with other
comedians of course I want to kill
harder than when were at the comedy
store of course I want to kill as hard
as you killed of course I want to be as
funny as you are like of course I want
to like sell as many tickets or more
ticket of course right but I don't feel
competitive with comics I hated like
being the last to be picked for
dodgeball I hated it like between me I
just don't like competing with somebody
else and the roasts always felt like
that leading up to it for me it was
what's he doing which you know like it
was and then before was like who's gonna
go when and what order and I felt like I
was against comedian and they're like
wouldn't tell you I don't like the way
they treated you well
like you're like who are you guys out to
right now like we've got two weeks I'd
love to start writing jokes like we're
not gay we can't tell you and I'm I'm on
the fucking Road I don't write for
variety I'm not gonna spoil this for you
laughs if you're talking about coke yeah
help me you're talking to Hulk Hogan so
I can write some jokes that's and they
would never do it that did always always
bother me and then they I didn't like
the way they would cut things up that I
remember on the Roseanne roasts
I walked in I think they had like 12
people on the dais I had like like 16
jokes I had like one joke for each
person and then for four Roseanne and
they're like Anthony we need to weigh
more I got a night off
you just can't cut me Wow so you
basically did that so that you weren't
gonna shoot ten minutes that they could
cut down to five so you were control of
the cut I just thought of a great joke
for each person I'm not gonna have us
like a B joke yeah that they could use
in case I was like I want to kill
because they would tell me they did the
way you tell jokes I was like Geraldo
where I ranted I would tell a joke and
then sit there and went to the laughs
died all the way down and they were like
you're so great because we can use your
laughs for other people no I was like
don't do that I want to I want to win
you know I want to win the rose haha I
don't want everyone to be killing as
hard as me because they're getting my
laughs right literally yeah I do love it
because I remember I think it must be
the Trump roast like I like that when
you're killing you kind of get bored
I got like impatient I'm like okay no I
know I know I wrote it I know it's a
good joke because I feel like the roasts
have such a desperation to them as such
a anxiety to them and to me that's like
that's not how I like to perform
stand-up that's not how I like to
operate in the world and I just was like
this is just so stressful and it's
taking the joy out of comedy for me you
know and I also don't like insulting
people that aren't comedians I just
makes me it's fun and I love right like
I love it on some level but I think the
roast like I the reason I fell in love
them because
comedians talking shit to each other and
people that it felt like a fair fight it
felt like the other person could
retaliate like people like how did you
go so hard after Joan Rivers house
because I knew she was gonna fucking
kill me that's why you know I got
thought Lampanelli wouldn't respect me
for the you're cool you know I thought
she'd be like what a pussy he didn't
have a joke for me and afterwards she
was the opposite she was like I would
like thank you so much for that and I
was like oh you appreciated that and got
it I thought you would be like what a
wouldn't come back at me yeah we do this
is how we show love to each other yeah
you know so it and then I also like a
couple little things like I remember
Geraldo
on the red carpet once before the roast
said something that just like like filed
into my hippocampus like didn't really
process it until a couple years later
after I'd been in the business for a
little while and had some sort of like
public like what are abstence ibly
called like failures right if you have
two seasons of a show it's a fail it's a
huge failure right I mean even when I
made a show that went six season sevens
ago your show got canceled it's like
dude 120 episodes yeah I'm good with
that like I know so I got a show the
only people just fucking like can't even
get a pilot like to get to that level
it's almost like making fun of a one-hit
wonder you're like do you know how hard
it is to be a one-hit wonder as it as a
band you know like what an insane level
that is to get to like you can make fun
of me if you want but I know know the
irony is that my failures you don't even
know about mm-hmm my success is - your
failure so I remember um I remember you
know well we would go to a lot was this
like your show failed and you your shows
get canceled or you know it was like
Geraldo you can't get a show on the air
or whatever that was like a big thing
that people go to with all doe-eyed like
his acting career or whatever and he was
going on the red carpet and people were
you know it's always like am it's like
open mic or comics that are interviewing
and they think it's funny to like be
mean to their hero they're just
panicking right and someone was just
like so like you like can't get a show
on the air right like that's what
everyone makes fun of you about what do
you think about that and he just goes
when did it become so embarrassing to
just be a comedian for a living and in
and it really just affected me you know
and I was like I'm fine to get made fun
of for my appearance I'm finding it made
fun of her being a whore even though I
was always in like a monogamous
relationship like I'm
I'd never dated a comic like fine that
I'm sleeping my way to the top like what
did I fuck one of the women at Comedy
Central I just you know none of it made
any sense but as soon as people go after
your career it just felt weird to go
after what I D it was so hard for me to
not see myself as a failure anyway even
when I was succeeding and I was like I
don't need you guys to be my like
reiterating my inner monologue of this
sort of impossible standard of
perfection yeah I just do if they go
after your career it means like I think
you're there means you have a career so
if they do it means they have nothing
else yeah they call you a whore they've
got unless you like got busted being a
whore like it's like baby just had
nothing else to do for you well cuz I
and that I think is ultimately when I
stop doing it because it's like I when I
first did it I there's nothing to make
fun of your whore like that was all like
fine but then but then I sort of was
like I just had too many raw nerves like
I know exactly what the jokes they're
gonna write out and they're gonna hurt
my feelings
I know you're gonna go after like a
canceled show or say the things that I
did aren't good and like I don't get to
go like you guys know that I don't do
every job on the show and that I wasn't
happy with that episode either and like
we ran out of time and ran out of money
and you know my mom had a stroke right
so I couldn't be that like I just think
you can't I just did I and I also felt
like I was starting to set a bad example
because I was gonna have to laugh when
people said that and I was like I just
don't want to train people to think they
can talk to me that way yes yes like
it's starting to I just would like to
have more dignity than that yeah you
know and I always think about it cuz I'm
like if if one of our friends if Rogen
or someone did a roast will we do it I
feel like we'd have to he would never do
it so I feel like we know like there's
someone to be like who would it be like
it's Louie like imagine that roast I
mean I I would that is one of the only
roasts are be like I'm going up third
like every time they announce a new one
I'm like mmm cuz they kick kind of
kicked me off like I remember doing the
Roseanne roast and they tried to make
that a classier you were the problem on
that set not not because of that but
like it was all older women and so I was
like I was very careful not to make an
old woman
yeah I mean so I was like but I was good
with that but I was also so much meaner
than everyone else was hmm that it was
like a problem like people were like
booing me and I feel like I was on Trump
a little bit I tell a joke about who was
who's the woman from married with
children the mom katey sagal katey sagal
and she's amazing she's sitting next to
me and she's like I didn't know they
made fun of me too and I was like
Katie you're like the best like I'm the
meanest guy here and my joke is like a
love letter to you you know and my joke
referenced I was like katey sagal she
was unmarried with the children the show
that changed comedy Sons of Anarchy the
show that took action to a whole new
level and how and 8 simple rules the
show that killed John Ritter and the
joke kills but then fucking Clint
Eastwood's ex-wife is sitting right
behind the dais and she's bombed out of
her mind and she starts screaming at me
oh Jesus
and does not stop until I finished my
set so for the whole set and I'm kind of
like I'm kind of hearing something and
I'm singing people the dais turn around
and look again like telling you to stop
and no one no one goes up and says like
knock it off and she just screamed to
the end just wasted because she was
friends with John Ritter and screamed
the entire time I ran into at a
restaurant and I wanted to be like do
you remember me
fuck you but I was like don't like don't
do it leave it alone leave it and just
let it go but I was like furious and
examples like that I'm trying to class
it up and then realizing they couldn't
yeah it was yeah there was had this
fantasy that they would get George
Clooney you know into the days would be
like Brad Pitt and stuff and have a Rat
Pack kind of thing and I was like why
wouldn't it for them why would he and if
he was going to why would he do it with
you I mean people only really do that to
fix a PR nightmare mm-hmm exactly right
so then the Franco roasts happened and
they were like we got Franco we're gonna
have Natalie Portman we're gonna have
Kate Hudson and they were like we don't
want Anthony and it wasn't Comedy
Central it was like the Franco team and
those guys who were just like anybody on
that we don't want someone coming up and
like crushing our friends and we wanted
to be more friendly and fun and that
Kent Alterman was like I'm gonna talk to
them about it I was like I don't want to
show up but I don't want to be like like
if you don't wanna invite me to the
party
to go to your party I don't wanna be the
guy that you like make show up yeah yeah
I never did one again oh never did again
and I didn't miss it it's so it like
there's so much work that goes into
those jokes for me anyway like I
couldn't just like just ran it was like
these had to be these like perfect bomb
yeah but after three I just felt like
it's gonna be diminishing returns I also
feel like the I don't I just feel like
they were better when people were a
little more ratchet like it's like now
they're getting like oscar-winners like
they're going for just more like famous
like beloved people and I feel like the
I love the roast when it was like Flavor
Flav and Brigitte Nielsen and people
with no self respect but I'll go even
further and I'll say that you ruined the
roasts okay because I followed your
example I saw you on the roast and I
knew you and I was like oh like my
mother's like and I always had what you
call aspirational jealousy when I would
see a friend do something that I wanted
to do I was excited for them I was never
jealous I was like if she's doing it
that means I could do it one day but you
went up and you went fucking
scorched-earth yeah you weren't like
like you know there's like like Jonah
Hill on a roast was like like would tell
a joke and I bet I'm just kidding I love
you and you didn't fuck with that at all
like you just went so hard that I was
like that's how you do it like you don't
like Jeff Ross is chummy and I get the
end when he's like we only roast the
ones we love he means it you won't like
that now but I was like that's the
template no and I felt like they got so
much meaner after you got there because
I was the next one in and I went like
Darth Vader on them and I thought that
like people like it just made the roast
it made the stakes that much higher that
you had to destroy it that's in thank
you first of all I took I certainly
meant it as a comic and I'm so sorry I
know it helped it gave me the blueprint
for what to do and I don't know and I
think it was and I never I try not to
bring up sort of like being a girl in
comedy like who cares like I think for
the most part nobody's thinking about
that except female comedians like were
the ones that are so obsessed with it
you know so I but I do think I had a lot
to prove and I had to earn my place
there
I was so pissed off because I had been a
writer on the roast for a couple roast
they they were gonna put me on a roast
and then cancelled me the Larry the
Cable Guy one I was booked for that and
then they said never mind I feel like I
had been fucked with and dicked around
with and and being in those writers
rooms for longest time and I mean I
remember when I first got the the job
they only hired me because I wrote a
joke that they wanted to use I wrote
like a packet of like 16 pages of jokes
and sent it and I had my manager just
send it in my managers like no they
don't hire any people there's the crew
of people they hire and that's it like
in that day there were like five dudes
we know em all they're all hilarious but
they don't take in new people certainly
not there was no girls on the rows and
then um I wrote a that's some more told
on the flavor flav roast which was Flav
you look like what Magic Johnson should
look like right now
and they wanted to use it and they told
me they were like we want to use this
joke so we need to hire you for a week
like they didn't even want me in the
room with them they didn't want me
pitching and I just slowly kind of
chipped away and they renewed me for the
next week like and even the next year I
had to fight to get it again like they
just it was just very hard to impress
them and make them like me and then sag
it I wrote some jokes I think that were
kind of good and then I did a roast of
Steve Tisch and videoed it like it was
like a charity roast and they send it to
commie central they said great we're
gonna put her on coke to me I wrote they
took me off it like it just was like I
just felt like by the time I got there I
had so much hate in my heart oh yeah
that a lot of it was just truly you know
at the network at comedy at the writers
like I was mad at the writers for like
not taking me seriously I got mad
because when I did the Trump roast like
did people loved me in the room when I
wrote for the Hasselhoff roast because I
was just like fun and laughed at
everything was just like it's that's
more fun than actually doing the roast
because it's like yeah four weeks of
just a good that's 2:00 in the morning
so you mean is shit yeah yeah my first
roast was Trump they were all like
rooting for me and happy yeah and then
on Sheen they were like we got you like
we got so we were getting you this time
like and I was like what do you mean
you're getting me like we're not friends
like it was like they turned on you that
I was like this is I don't this isn't
like healthy yeah this seems like you
guys are bitter and angry about me that
I I don't want to be here no they want
you to stay down yeah they want you to
stay so yeah and I felt like I just had
so much to sort of prove and my whole
deal
I mean even today like when I get lost
on jokes I really just think about
making comedians laugh I don't I just
that's I just was like would this joke
make Anthony Jeselnik laugh like that's
the way I would think about it with the
rose and I was trying to make Joan laugh
i'll it was like just try to make Joan
laugh that's all you can do just if you
can make Joan Rivers laugh you have
succeeded here tonight if she I don't
care what the audience is even fucking
doing just stick with her okay time to
read some ads hey Benson do people like
when I sing during the ads no I don't
think you gonna make me stop doing that
I think I started singing because I got
excited to talk about smooth balls
nothing is more exciting okay so I'm
just gonna do a little personal story
here I'm not gonna lie I've I have a
quarantine hookup okay and Spall's are
just smooth as a marble paperweight and
I'm starting to think that maybe he
listens to my podcast and got manscaped
because me I haven't even read the copy
and I knew exactly where to go with this
I think he's listening to podcast and
heard us talk about the lawnmower 3.0
and is the only men it's a it can you
explain why I - just the fans here
basically know why yes that's my job
with my giant teeth leave the balls
shredding to me and my huge horse face
and my unmanned acure nails you
shouldn't be doing it yourself at home
but you know because every time I saw
guys before manscaped shave their balls
they'd have to put it up
their leg up on the tub and stretch it
out because it's like an elephant ear
you know you gotta pull it but you don't
have to do that with the lawnmower 3.0
it's easier now oh look it's waterproof
cordless well that's key because you
don't want to perfectly shore your balls
in the trip over a cord and then
dislocate your knee and not be able to
you know let your balls shine and all
their glory that night because you have
an injury from shaving them that would
be a nightmare third-generation trimmer
features a cutting-edge ceramic blade to
prevent manscaping accidents millions of
balls are about to be Knick free thanks
to manscaped its advanced skin safe
technology see this is what see I wish
manscaped
was around when I was in my 20s yeah so
you get a perfect package it's called
you'll find the manscaped crop preserver
it's an anti chafing ball deodorant oh
gosh I will buy this for you guys
personally a ball deodorant Oh
where have you been all my life Baldy Oh
door answer your balls aren't gonna
smell like clam chowder and old scallops
because you know who has to smell your
balls us us me and Benton you guys can't
smell your own balls you don't
understand how swampy and war fie they
smell guys Luke how come she won't go
down on me because your balls smell like
oatmeal that's why okay pull it together
manscaped subscribe to the perfect
package sorry I'm stuttering I'm just so
flustered by thinking about these smooth
delightful waxy balls against my chin
that's the other thing you guys don't
understand when you have stubble in your
balls it gets our chin all red and crazy
we're already having to wear masks I'm
already getting enough breakouts on my
chin I don't need your ball stubble
clogged up my pores subscribe to the
perfect package get a new replacement
blade refill for your lawn mower trimmer
delivered to your door every three
months you have to go anywhere you don't
got to get
a virus you can just stay home and
receive your trimmer stays fresh stays
clean for a limited time or subscribers
get not one but two free gifts the shed
travel bag it's a thirty nine dollar
value so don't sleep on that and the
patented high-performance an anti
chafing manscaped boxer briefs cute this
is a perfect package for your perfect
package feel free to send us photos of
your package tagged me
I'm sure manscape won't love that I'm
soliciting dictation is that send me
proof that manscape worked on your balls
just send me a couple of photos I just
want to see how there's no nicks on your
scrotum get 20% off plus free shipping
with the code Whitney at manscape comm
it's my goal in life that when that
manscaped and i have such a deep
relationship and you guys buy so many
products of them because of me that when
you google me my nudes don't come up
instead manscaped comes up you know when
it says like you google something it's
like Whitney Cummings then I'll be like
did you mean manscaped that's how
closely I want to be associated why not
why can't why can't I I've been talking
about shaving your balls for truly 14
years go back to my first special I
spent the entire time talking about how
guys should blow dry their pubes so they
don't get all like moldy and asbestos
ewwww so this is in whew I was wearing
fuchsia lipstick that was a mistake
but I have been banging this drum for
years now finally manscaped listened do
yourself a favor
use the right tools for the jobs you
guys love tools I'm dating this guy he's
like 30 years old and I tried to stir my
coffee with a spoon ease of no you got
to get the frother like guys you guys
need machines for even simple tasks so
trust me you're gonna love this you're
gonna get 20% off and free shipping with
the code Whitney at manscape com I
really hope the guy I'm dating is
listening to this please get manscaped
that's 20% off with Free Shipping at
manscape com
use the code Whitney stop having tangy
balls this episode is sponsored by blue
chill one of my favorite things to talk
about this it cools these sexuals out
now
okay now let's be honest let's just be
real that's what I do that's my brand
real nothing worse than a dick that
doesn't work okay a lot of things don't
work right now including human beings
you know the one thing that has no
excuse to not work your dick let's be
honest the only thing we really can have
right now without feeling like we're
catching kovat is good dick okay it is
your job to make sure your dicks on
point during this pandemic that's why
you need blue chu brings you the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but you just pop it in and chew it you
can take them any time day or night even
on a full stomach and since they're
chewable they work twice as fast as a
pill see that's it that's why this
company's genius the worst is we're
trying to you're trying to get some
hanky panky you're trying to get that
hubba-hubba on he runs takes a pill you
by the time it kicks in you're over it
you're done you've already rubbed one
out to the basketball game or whatever
is your thing I don't know
that show you on Netflix whatever
whatever your thing is a dodo puppy
video I don't judge people okay
but I do know that when I want to dick I
want it when I want it and I don't want
to wait
blue chew fast easy way to enhance your
performance because guess what right now
everyone's pushing it okay if I was
living with somebody I loved I wouldn't
be in love with them anymore
the only thing keeping couples together
right now during this nightmare
quarantine is good sex so if you lose
that then what do you have nothing just
you and your mask alone blue chew its
prescribed online by licensed physicians
positions
it's our word physicians you don't have
to know the doctor's office or wait in
line at a pharmacy and contract that
miss Rona nope shipped right to your
door in a discrete package so none of
your neighbors are gonna know what's
what made in the USA love that since
blue troop repairs and ships direct
they're cheaper than a pharmacy okay
thank God some things makes sense
financially right now we have a special
deals deal for our listeners okay I'm
getting flustered because I'm thinking
about hard dick visit blue to calm get
your first shipment free when you use
special promo code Whitney pay just five
dollars for shipping I know some guys
that I'm with are gonna need blue chew
because my personality makes your penis
go bye-bye blue to makes it go oh hello
I'm back blue blue2 dot-com promo code
Whitney try it for free get your girl to
fall back in love with you
blue chew is the better cheaper faster
choice and we sync them for sponsoring
the podcast how come they haven't sent
me any I'd like some I'm dating a guy
who's 30 but you never know I feel like
my annoying voice is gonna give him a
reptile dysfunction any day now you gave
me a great piece of advice which is how
I knew you're gonna be cool to me when I
sat down next to you for Trump and I was
like do you look at them when you say
the joke like do you look at them and
you go I look at them for the setup and
then I don't for the punchline like I
moved for the punchline and I was like
that's so great got it and that like
saves you because people are just like
they're looking at you like ah ha and
then you say the joke and they're like
they get upset or they start looking at
the teleprompter to see what you're
going to say and I didn't want to see
that I was like look at them for the
setup and then turn and say the
punchline yes it helped me I did that
for every joke I've ever told on the
roast that's so interesting I blacked
out a lot of the Donald Trump roast
because I remember first of all I just
started dressing like sluttier and
sluttier every roast by the time we got
to Donald Trump I was in a miniskirt
that was so fucking sure I
couldn't even like position myself on
the couch and it was sequins and it was
digging into my skin and I was so
distracted by it
and I was also very thrown by a very
weird exchange with Larry King was very
rude backstage just shitty for no reason
and wasn't Jerry wasn't Jerry Springer
on that am I making that up Springer was
on hustle HOF but who King was on Larry
King Snoop Dogg lunch romp the situation
trumpet there were someone else oh the
situation was on Trump that's I was just
a lot a weird interaction backstage I
was no camaraderie there wasn't a fun to
it Larry King was shitty
so I started adding more I like I added
a couple jokes about him right before we
started after he was shitty to me about
how like I hope he dies soon or
something like that do you remember that
he fell and you caught him you caught
him I was like I can't live you're
strong enough like it was it was you
than me than Larry King and he stayed I
think his went Crocs or something and he
stood up at the very end of it and took
a step and fell and I was just I just
kind of watched him go cause it's like
an old person noting like I don't want
to break any bones and I swear to God
you were like one-armed like boom gotcha
lyric and I was just like holy shit leg
Whitney's got some guns you saved his
life
I regret that it's weird I went on Larry
King's like show he's like a talk show
yeah and I did it for I think it was my
book like and I don't know if he's just
getting old and like he's like Daddy
Dottie old man by I think he's I so you
say that being codependent made you a
slut like I heard that noise oh you know
it's like a weird sound and literally he
just kept looking I mean I was like oh
he's lugging gone I'm a we talked I
figured what I was promoting but we
talked for like like half an hour about
comedy and like my comedy and stuff and
one point I go you ever seen my comedy
and he goes no this is the with the
fucking really choir like why are we
talking like where's this on kwibi like
we're even is this show yeah
but yes I remember the Trump rows being
very scary and I remember like why
remember it's weird your first roast I
feel like everything every roast after
your first Rose is just trying to
recreate the first one you don't want it
to be you don't it be a letdown like
this sheen one was the most pressure I
felt because it was like I don't want
people to think Oh Trump was like Trump
was a fluke okay somebody wrote his
jokes
and that was like machine roast was only
like six months after Trump it wasn't
like it was a yearly thing it was really
quick she said I felt so much pressure
on that sheen roast right and then I
remember yeah the Hasselhoff roast I
felt all this pressure and I remember I
remember getting a lot of fucking
trouble for this joke and I don't think
they aired it but there was a joke that
this is my favorite kind of roast laughs
when there's like a joke hits and I was
like who and then they start laughing
there's a gasp and then attention
release and the joke was so brutal and
it's my favorite jokes because there's
no art to it it's a very artless bald
joke it was just Pam Anderson you've
dated Tommy Lee kid rock and Bret
Michaels why don't you just save
yourself some time and drink a vat of
Magic Johnson's blood I think you heard
it right so oh yes because um legal I
think someone tried to sue me you can't
just say people having to you you and
Jeff Ross were two of the people I
remember who they would be like you
can't tell that joke and you'd be like
mm-hmm and then you would go and tell
the joke right and I was like oh you're
just allowed to do that like I had
ridden all these jokes about Mike Tyson
and like the week before they're like oh
no rape stuff and I was like but he went
to jail for it like what and why didn't
you tell us this that's right like if he
signed on because of this like why
didn't you tell me right away why am i
finding out when I turn in my jokes yeah
that these are unacceptable I was really
mad and I wish I just done I was told
about the about Snoop Dogg I wasn't had
to bring up like a murder charge or
something and I was just like okay yeah
then also there was always something and
I think people would be interested to
hear this on every roast there was
something that was like off-limits for
the writers and off limits for the
comedians there's always something that
whoever the person being roasted would
come in with some kind of stipulation
like there was like I think Saget said
like please don't make fun of the Olsen
twins more like yeah that's good
and then I think Jones was don't make
fun of Melissa I don't go too hard after
Melissa Shatner was the wife the ground
right I think Pam Anderson was the kid
in the pool there's a lot of dead people
in pools yes and then uh what was Hogan
Oh a Hasselhoff was I think it was
Brooke Hogan's daughter stay away from
her his daughter I think that was what
we weren't allowed to make jokes about
which I don't remember she was gonna
come and yeah then it was it because no
it wasn't the daughter it was the son
cuz Hogan's son had just killed his
friend and like it wasn't the daughter
was the son right
the daughter almost came to the show but
I'm the sign there were no jokes about
him
there was a second where Kelsey Grammer
was gonna be on a roast and they were
like you can't talk about his family
members that got murdered there was I
mean you just realize like Jesus like
I'm Tyson they would like no rape and
don't talk about his son who died like
one in treadmill Isaac shred and I was
like who the fuck even I wouldn't write
a joke about that like of course not can
you please not make a joke about the
dead baby in the pool you're like got it
yeah from a week ago like yeah like yeah
I'm gonna leave that one alone I got it
you don't need it we're not fucking
animals Jesus and then what was Trump's
you can't say I have less money than I
say I do whoa mm-hmm I remember the
Trump roast was was wild because I'm not
like coming forward I don't care like
but he was like a low hand on the back
guy like instantly Lohan on the back and
I remember he was literally there were
jokes about him running for president or
like I remember going in to
cross-reference jokes know the guy he's
running for president Oh God like why
even do a joke about that that's never
gonna happen that's such like a dumb
premise like never gonna happen silly
rumor
so I remember I didn't do any jokes
about him running for president cuz I
just thought it was like too dumb of a
premise I remembered the joke that hurt
him the most that I did and I went hard
on him yes but I had a joke just about
like his failed casino business and that
one you could tell he was like mad like
he almost was just like cut that out Wow
you know it's interesting like I got
asked to do Alec Baldwin and I thought
about it don't I just I thought about it
and then um you know for a litany of
reasons you know I didn't do it but I
kind of is like and I'm not like in this
climate and cancel culture like I
canceled culture I think for the most
part is Mirage it's it's a it's a lot of
shit on Twitter I mean anything people
say it actually just makes more topics
taboo for us it makes them funnier when
we do make jokes about them you're
actually cancel culture helps dark
comedy exactly you know it's like like
why do you make rape jokes it's like
because you told me I can that's right
that's the only reason that's the only
reason I'm doing that is because that
you're saying anything but that you're
like let's do that that's what comedy is
we you draw the line then we cross it so
the more lines you draw the more we're
gonna cross like you're just helping us
be funnier basically you know and I
think for me the only thing wild are
about outraged culture or canceled
culture is the comedian spent so much
time talking about it it's just like it
dominates every comedians like I know I
can't say this and people in a Middle
America are like you can't why not a lot
of the comics who talk about it have
nothing in their act that would ever be
part of canceled culture so I can't say
the n-word I'm like you have 45 minutes
on TSA PreCheck yeah talking about yeah
you were never doing that you just want
to be a victim so badly exactly you want
to be like an edgy comic that was making
jokes about the trans community like you
were never doing that and I never wanted
to complain ever it's like you want to
get mad like get mad that's okay yes I
don't care interested but like some of
my favorite movies you know I've been
like movies that are like most people
would find unwatchable and like like a
horrific viewing experience but I'm like
like have you ever seen the movie
martyrs no there's a French movie there
was a thing like there was a a movement
called French new extremism like it was
like a horror thing where they just
fucking like went for it we're martyrs
is Jesus it's not even skin
they made it didn't American remake that
sucks but the original was just like
it's a gut punch scene I was like I
don't mind I don't mind gut punches two
young women were both victims of abuse
as children embark on a bloody quest for
revenge and then you find themselves
plunge into a living hell of depravity
yes and that's not doesn't even really
describe the movie like it's just like
it's fucking with the audience that I'm
like I love that movie
so if like if someone says I hate your
comedy I don't go why I'm like mm-hmm
like I don't care
they're people who love it but I don't
need to know why I know why it's okay
but you know what I love about watching
you perform and I've talked about this
with other people is I think everyone's
laughing and maybe for different reasons
some people are nervous yes and I love
nervous laughs I love attention release
laughs I love a I'm in church and I'm
not supposed to be laughing laughs I
love the shaking your head no laughing
hysterically so good it's almost
performance art in a way cuz there's
times I mean especially now and I saw
you at the store back when we were doing
stand-up you were doing something about
you know what to not say to a trans
woman like you were in that and as soon
as you said it everyone's like like
there was this it just proof that
canceled culture just makes these areas
more ripe to make jokes about it adds
tension to it yes there was a as soon as
you said there was a good mmm in the
room and it just was like an explosion
when you did not give a fuck and refused
to feel fear and walk on eggshells
around it yeah you know so it's just
like it's so fun to watch everybody
laugh for different reasons you also
have this ability to make people feel
smarter than they are
thank you that's I think the skill of
like you know I remember like when to
meet you Martin like I remember seeing
him when I first started stand-up I feel
like when we started he was kind of like
the thing yes kind of right like he was
like we became the thing I remember I
remember like discovering him like a
year and and being like oh my god like
smart one-liners like I'm in he was like
the Beatles I mean I mean LA when we
started he was like Largo just it was
just like royalty right and what he did
which
I thought was really interesting and I
strived for in the beginning was he gave
you a joke to take home and tell your
friends he gave you a joke you are able
to recite right why don't they make
cakes that say you're adopted or
whatever you know like you you're not
gonna fuck up the delivery like Dan
Mintz does this of course mitch hedberg
and steven wright did this and you know
it's like Hedberg like you could you had
to know Hedberg to like for someone to
repeat the Hedberg joke to you otherwise
it wouldn't make sense because he was
such a part of it that's where's Demetri
it's it could live on the page right you
know totally and you could tell it to
someone else and flirt with a girl and
you know say it at the water cooler in
the next day and crack people up you do
that too in a way that makes people feel
like naughty and smart and funny you
know like I mean I'm literally the last
guy that I was hanging out with would
like do your jokes and he didn't okay
job thank you
[Laughter]
yeah it's interesting they cancel
culture thing like I find myself
fighting with comedians about it all the
time because I'm like dude this is like
2,000 people on Twitter like why are you
spending all of these podcasts in the
first 10 minutes of your set talking
about this also ignore it like if
somebody on Twitter like I've had I've
I've got a lot of jokes about pedophilia
you know child abuse stuff like that and
somebody would like somebody had they
put them all together and then like
screenshotted it and I put it up as like
we're gonna get him he was like it's
like one of those like Roseanne goes
down we got to take someone out the
front from the left down yeah and people
started coming after me
and every time I just retweeted I'm not
gonna fight with you
I just retweet it and like I don't like
it's like you can't hurt me that that
was interesting because I mean when all
that started half an hour just was like
are they gonna start just taking roast
jokes and like there's a couple Robin
Quivers roast jokes that are I mean that
if you were to put take them out of
context like that you guys could do this
whenever you want it I think of roast
everything's okay yeah I think about
podcasts none is something not to yeah
yes yeah but people have talked so much
shit yeah that it's like that Milo yes
I'm saying it wrong yeah that dude got
taken down for talking about pet
philia on a podcast right it's like on
Twitter somebody gets SNL you searches
Twitter for the n-word for the f-word
for different things I find them
yeah there was a way to do with podcasts
yeah see people going down left and
right
yeah because especially in the beginning
when you're like no one's listening to
this it doesn't matter you know I talked
wild shit on my podcast and then people
get upset later and I'm like oh you
listen to that like it doesn't occur to
me like yeah hundreds of thousands of
people listen to this and you don't like
you think of it as just the three of you
in a room yeah I know it's it's I think
that's part of why Howard Stern was got
so much for so long out of people and
has continued to he keeps his studio
very small and very intimate and within
the first couple minutes you kind of
forget that you're not just like hanging
out with a friend you've got that
millions of people are listening and
then you like talk about like anal sex
and you walk out you have like 400
missed calls from your fuck what did I
say and they're gonna black out yeah so
question why are you not an instrument
honestly my numb I might might go to
answers I'm just like too old like it
doesn't like it just felt like the whole
person thing to me
Twitter felt like as a comedian like I
can use this and I would love if Twitter
ended they just deleted Twitter as a
whole I wouldn't get on any other
platform I'd be like I'm done with this
but I'm not a big picture guy uh-huh
you know I don't take a lot of pictures
yeah but I don't like take pictures of
it someone takes a picture of me and
sends it to me I'm like cool I'm glad
it's there I look like that but I just
don't like it just felt it felt weird
for me to play into it
I almost play against my looks uh-huh
you know that I didn't want to play into
that well couldn't you just post clips
of your standup I mean it is such it is
such an anomaly for not being on
Instagram I mean it's like having a
website at this one yeah I just truly
don't like you got I don't judge
Schuller but I don't judge people for it
like I'm not like oh they're on
Instagram like I think that good for you
for doing it like Aziz Ansari uh-huh
when in the beginning was so good at
marketing himself yeah and I was so bad
at it and I never like thought he was
like a less of a comic or something I
was like I'm like it's cool that you're
comfortable doing that huh but I would
not be able to do it you know I was not
able to kind of promote myself in that
way I had to just kind of
just go and and forge ahead like
Instagram just makes me uncomfortable
well you know what's interesting about
it is that people who what you've done
is you've created this sort of mystique
about yourself like you have this you're
kind of an enigma and and you've gotten
incredibly popular but people that like
you think like that you're like only
they know about you even though it's not
true yes you've remained you you are
able to be mainstream and sort of have a
cult following at the same time they
think they're in a cult following but
they don't understand that your populace
Sarah Silverman said that one she's like
all of my fans think they're the only
one which makes them like love you even
more and I was like great like great
like no one else would get that but I
like it when my fans get mad at me cuz I
like because I'll give an opinion and
they're like wait what yeah this guy who
does that I love cuz he does whatever he
wants isn't doing what I want it's like
saying I don't do like I thought he was
like this it's like my thing is that I
do whatever I want
and that changes sometimes you know I
mean people talk about being woke yeah I
just means educated that's like I have
become more educated over my years
that's I wouldn't joke about some things
that I would have joked about before I
don't regret the jokes I probably
wouldn't tell a rape joke today mm-hmm
you know I probably wouldn't tell a joke
using the word retarded yeah even though
I have those who have yeah I mean and I
don't regret them yeah they did you
watch that Chris Rock documentary about
bringing the pain no it was like w kamau
Bell produced this thing for like Annie
and it was like an hour special just
about bring the pain and like how big
that was it's amazing oh and they talked
about his famous bit about like I love
black people I hate you know the n-word
and yeah people it's like a bunch of
celebrities now being like I wish he
kind of hadn't done that like you almost
like gave white people permission to use
the word and then it cuts to Chris and
he's like I stand by it
he's like that was a great joke he's
like probably wouldn't do it today but
like he didn't say that because like I
stand by it like it was a great joke and
stand by a great show yeah like when
Sarah Silverman's like I hate I disown
all these jokes I'm like you don't have
to do that yeah you could be like I
wouldn't do it today but I still stand
it's still a great show totally and were
trash because we laughed at it mm-hmm do
you know what I mean there's also that
you're also
in a way by accident I think trying to
take responsibility being accountable so
it's like oh now we're shitheads because
I love that special well I think people
don't get mad at jokes like someone's
not like I'm not like I'm mad like rapes
not funny why'd you tell that joke but
I'm out of the joke they're mad that
everyone laughed at it that's right
that's right so they're upset about that
that's how you know like who big what's
funny about rape I'm like nothing that's
why the joke has to be just like crazy
contraption to get you to laugh after
hearing that word yeah
Alzheimer's like how do you introduce
that word and then get to a place so
people can laugh because most people
were just like this is it yeah you know
that I I just I love that challenge
that's what you're saying you're not
saying don't make a joke with the word
retarded a joke
don't make a bad cheap one don't lean on
that word so to me it's like the thing
with Shane Gillis which is like I'm sure
we'll get in trouble for this but it's
like it was cuz he was on a podcast and
I know it just wasn't a well-formed Jo
it wasn't a joke it wasn't a joke period
it was just I'm gonna talk about getting
Chinese food and I'm gonna use racial
slurs throughout like I talked about
race all the time yeah I've never used a
racial slur yes you know what I mean
like I just I just that's like that's
it's not a line yeah it's a preference
you know it's the language that's right
but the topic is enough limits like I
love talking about race and racism but I
probably wouldn't use the word black
right
you know black lives matter like had an
effect ride like I tweaked some things
yeah and you know the I had a joke about
hate crimes that I dropped and I never
dropped jokes but after the Pittsburgh
synagogue shooting yeah I was like I
don't even want to like I don't want my
character to be on that side you know
also like it's just but it's also you
just know something is gonna get a
different reaction because when you say
that all of a sudden everyone it's a
different it's not gonna get the same
laugh also it's the context has changed
for the thing you're referencing like I
just you know this whole you know
pandemic is it's interesting I was going
back and looking at sort of my set and
what I was doing before this and I
realized every joke is now either not
funny because of what happened or funny
for a different reason like for example
I was working on this bit about how
every time you shake a man's hand they
give you feedback on how strong your
handshake was it's like that's you can't
even make that joke it you'd have to go
well before back when we could shake it
like mm-hmm
someone saying strong handshake is the
least weird
thing about shaking hands right now like
that jokes just dead you know like it I
think that a lot of people comedians
don't want to just like evolve with
reality you know like but that was such
a good joke that was working well does
it work anymore because things changed
things shifted what I think is
interesting in is now for me I don't
know if you get this too but those like
for the free speech comedians mm-hmm you
know the like I always say like if
you're talking about freedom of speech
like get the fuck out of here
yeah we're Americans yeah we all have
that no one's no ones like buying a
ticket to hear you for your freedom of
speech you have to be funny yeah don't
give me like I should be able to do this
because of freedom of speech if it was
funny enough he would be allowed to do
it and all those comics and all their
fans hate me because I because I'm like
you would think they'd be like big fans
but they're like like no like he's not
on our side they think I would be one of
them and I'm like no no I have to make
the joke great and I work really hard to
make it great in order to be able to toe
this line I can't just go up and like
say the thing but if you're a comedian
you have no freedom to not be funny no
zero that like you have given up the
freedom to not pay people laugh if they
paid money yeah but they think you
should I get like just like oh no just
know the audience I mean I'm the person
it's like the audience is always right
like comedy is a democracy there
laughing your that's what we're peddling
here we're not peddling uni and
conversely we're also not peddling clap
derp which is the new thing where if you
say something woke everyone's like yeah
we have to kind of clap at this because
or else were racist like that's the
other thing that is I think equally is
fucking obnoxious dude I'm not even
looking at the ad for this I swear to
god you realize that all these podcasts
you listen to all these these hacks okay
they read off the paper they go hi this
ad is brought you know crystally is just
like a robot he's like go go growing up
cereal was one of the best parts of
being a kid just lifeless soulless
passionless magic spoon swear to God
truly it's my favorite food I used to
wear to god I'm not even joking all I
have eaten this entire pandemic is the
fruity and chocolate magic spoon cereal
and it is honestly
the only thing that brings me any
happiness and I'm on Prozac so that is
saying a lot I'm not even gonna read
this out I mean I'll look at it if I
have to all right fine I'll read the ad
zero sugar 12 grams of protein see
that's it I sort of bike riding recently
and all of a sudden I'm building all
this muscle and now I know why because
I'm eating magic spoon all day and has
12 grams of protein 3 net grams of carbs
in each serving 4 flavors Coco fruity
frosted and blueberry dude I did
blueberry the other day with chocolate
oat milk oh damn
so good I wasn't even high it was just a
sober choice tastes amazing truly is I I
am not even joking
I made Benton order me an extra box of
this because they sent me one box or one
box of four boxes and I went through all
of them in literally two days I'm not
even kidding
Kito friendly gluten free grain free soy
free low carb GMO free what else do you
want in life that I'm not even joking
the fruity ones are truly my favorite
food not even kidding I'm not trying to
I'm not one of these podcast hosts who's
just trying to be a huckster and force
you to buy stuff to support their
podcast I don't need that I'm fine
without this okay but if you go to magic
spoon dot-com slash Whitney grab a
variety pack try it today I've actually
been posting this all over my social
media and there anyone pay me to do that
that's how much I like this product I'm
willing for you guys to think I'm
getting paid to post and do sponsored
content but I'm not not one of those
people okay I'm I mean it I just want
you to be happier
magic spoon is so confident their
product it's backed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they refund
your money Wow no questions asked I like
that the magic spoon dot-com site where
you get at magic spoon dot-com slash
Whitney use the code Whitney for free
shipping put my name on their screen
grab it send it to me tag me a lot of
you guys have been doing that and I see
a lot of you are enjoying magic spoon
thanks to me
we thank magic spoon for sponsoring the
podcast
really appreciate it thank you for
making an incredible product because if
it wasn't for magic spoon I would have
starved her in the quarantine because
it's the only thing I'll eat because I'm
a brat that's why I'm worried about when
comedy comes back from the pandemic mhm
because like remember like the month
after Trump got elected how terrible
comedy was how fucking terrible
everything was because every comic is
just this orange cheeto and you're like
we've all heard it it's like this is an
original now we're sick of this like
talk about anything else when we come
back from the pen down mic it's like get
ready for a lot of masks Joe yes you
know a lot of Purell jokes are coming
down the pike and it's like you're using
an emotion someone already has to cheat
you know what I mean or you're playing
into their guilt or you're playing into
their self right you're getting like
woke points that's not comedy you know
and also I think that's why touring is
so important and you see the difference
between comics who really tour and
really do the work or the ones that
don't because I remember my last special
I was working and everyone's talking
about me too that's all anybody was
talking about until the pandemic
canceled me to put a pin in that and and
I've ever taught anyone's talking about
LA so I write like an hour about me to
write and I go to Houston and I'm like
yeah so you know catcalling and you know
guys that pinched their asses at work
and this woman in the front row just
yelled take the compliment and move on
she was like what are you talking about
like we don't like and it was just you
know it's so important you know I think
to tour you know and you really do that
work in a way that's always inspires me
oh yeah I mean I think if you can tell
the comics who do you can tell the
comics who stay in LA the whole time
until they have an hour and then they
record it and the people who go
everywhere
yeah and do it in mind and so you said
something earlier that when you said
like the character like do you feel like
who you are on stage is a character cuz
I don't see it that way I I was like
rereading an article about myself and
someone I described it as like it's me -
the warmth you know there is some warmth
there and it just like I just kind of
take that away in order
be a little more of a villain yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh that's interesting I
just enjoy playing the villain so much
well it's nice because I think that it's
just like an absence I think people
don't understand like the boxing match
that is comedy I mean it's like it to me
I always when I see younger comedians
and think about myself as a medium like
oh you just can't let them have any
power and that's how they want it they
want you to be in charge you know like I
was um
with the canceled cultural thing
something that did blow my mind is I was
at The Comedy Store a couple months back
and a comedian that you could probably
guess was doing a joke about fat chicks
big joke about big chunk about fat
chicks and a woman like the third row
just went can you stop
I mean it was shock it was a it was a
wild heckle like we're used to like suck
my dick or what like that we can handle
but just could you stop there's a woman
everybody heard it it was that's like
every comedians nightmare that heckle
you know that's just the one we're not
we don't have a comeback for it you know
and and he sort was like huh and I was
like you first of all so interesting
that the audience is now like woo next
joke like comedians are jukeboxes now no
one would ever do that to you I had I
had one time I'll never forget Kentucky
they were like they're like move on next
like and I was like toward the end of my
said I've been killing and I was talking
about murder-suicide and they were like
enough of this and I go guys
I'm a movie you paid to see the movie
there I know you're upset right now
you're gonna be upset for a couple
minutes and it's only and I've got a bit
after that that's even worse
but everyone paid money to see this
movie I'm not changing it for you like
watch the movie do you think you walked
into a hornet's nest no I think it was I
think was a Late Show in fucking
Kentucky and it was just this one it was
in it that bit killed the rest of the
weekend the rest of the tour it was one
night that people were like they were
they were it was a check drop and they
were just like they just heard suicide
and we're like stop this well you know
you said of course you've seen Jim
Jefferies that video where he got
punched onstage yes and I believe it was
a suicide joke yeah you know that is a
fucking tricky I want to ask you because
we since we started together and since
we've seen so many people like
who are you excited to watch when you're
in a comedy club if they come by like do
you ever like I just mean are you ever
like I want to see what like I never get
to watch anyone set but is there anyone
you're like I can actually be a fan and
just watch this person I have that with
you I have it with sebat like there's a
couple people that I it's funny the only
comics I watch really on stage and I was
telling this to Rogan right at his
podcast are Rogan D'Elia and Sebastian
because those are the three comics that
I follow when I go to the store yeah you
know some that like sometimes Ali Wong
I'll see some of her yeah no we're all
like but like you did usually like three
people in between us I mean so it's like
I'm gonna be at the back bar chilling
like and I'll see some of it but like I
remember when I was in New York at the
Comedy Cellar
it was like David tells of religion you
know still is so like comics will go
downstairs and I went downstairs every
night to watch a towel yeah and then one
night I was on stage somewhere else and
I did one of his mannerisms cuz it's
like fun yeah what I mean it's like it's
just fun to do that I was like shit and
I went to the Comedy Cellar and I went
to st if you remember like st from the
cellar
we like books to sell her and like it's
like the the the you know the the
motherly figure of the seller yeah and I
was like st like confessional ii like st
i think you have to stop watching Dave
Attell like I'm starting to act like him
and I thought she was gonna be like oh I
guess you're not a real comic she goes
good more people should stop watching
Dave Attell oh yeah I mean I think you
so many people but I don't like I'm
worried about picking things up from the
mm-hmm you know there's very few comics
like you have to be like really absurd
like Nate bargatze yeah I love to watch
because it's like there's gonna be no
overlap no chance and I can just enjoy
it
it's surprising to me and enjoyable like
I like absurdism something you'd love
this guy he's dark it's like no I'm not
like if like if someone's like oh my
friend you remind me my friend I'm like
I bet I fucking hate your friend if I
met you I fucking hate you no I don't
want to see stuff like me so I can enjoy
everything but they can run into the
room and watch it's like I just don't
want anyone in my head interest I don't
want to hear any topic and be like oh
like yeah I want that it's just I always
wonder because people like always
minions are so miserable Angela and I
don't agree with that necessarily it's a
it's a wild blanket statement everyone's
miserable like it's like more dentists
kill themselves than anyone else like
what no one talks about that
yeah it's just we advertise it yeah we
just let everybody know right exactly
but uh I do think it's interesting that
we got into comedy because we loved it
and it's sort of being a comedian has
taken away the ability to enjoy it's
like you know like I was just hanging
out with this guy and all he talks about
his comedy like and I just and that
episode of Arrested Development and that
episodes of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia in that only God that
Anthony Jeselnik joke of that Chappelle
joke I'm just like oh like I just it's
all work to me it's all like ya know I
know that I know I fucking didn't think
of that Primus no like I got it no I
know I didn't put that job like all the
things that normally entertain people
that are there escape from their
problems or are to me have been toxified
and poisoned yes I realize that I can't
really enjoy television I can't really
enjoy comedy someone's like what's the
funniest show the past 20 years The
Sopranos yeah you know I mean like I
laughed my ass off and but it's got like
nothing to do with comedy
it just is legitimately funny yeah I had
a friend a long time ago say I've seen
so much comedy to do me you can make me
laugh is if you're a genius or my friend
I can watch a friend and laugh and enjoy
them having a good set or a bad set I
can watch a friend bomb yeah have a
great time and not in a bad way yeah
like I've definitely eaten and walked
offstage and seen Morgan Murphy being
like like just like delighted and it
doesn't bother me at all I'm like I'm
glad you got something out of it so what
are you doing all day you're not on
Instagram you can't watch TV what is
what's what are you doing like during
the pandemic or in Genesis both I mean
during the pandemic I read a lot and I
try to find excuses not to drink like
you asking me to do this knowing I had
to be on camera
yeah here and do this with you I didn't
drink all week really because I didn't
want to embarrass myself okay I didn't
want to show up looking puffy and shitty
and like this guy like this guy's been
letting himself go like I was like okay
I had this excuse there was one night
where I like poured myself a glass of
like vodka rocks
Moshe kasher called me was like hey
would you call him to our podcast
tonight and do this thing with us at
like nine o'clock at night and it was
like
in the afternoon yeah and I was like yes
and then I poured the drink away and
then like sat there and waited for the
podcast like it was like I need these
things to do yeah to keep myself beat
and it's like my therapist is like why
are you drinking so much I'm like
because it's boring his fuck yeah I'm
not a big TV guy if it wasn't for that
Chicago Bulls documentary I wouldn't be
watching anything but like reading to me
is almost like meditation and what are
you reading I just finished the Woody
Allen memoir oh really
getting phenomenal really but not him
yeah apropos of not the new one yes the
one that was random house like cancelled
and cancelled and then I went somewhere
else
Wow it's amazing it's funny it's light
it doesn't like get into the technical
stuff of his movies music I don't care
yeah it's like amazing to see what a
genius like that cared about in the end
dismissed as like what's important just
so you know fans of the pod oh no I hate
Woody Allen movies or I don't think I
don't think the movies are good or funny
like I know not a huge fan of the movies
couple like blue jazz I think is
brilliant and I think he's brilliant at
casting yes I just I've an Annie Hall
like I love because of her but I go back
and I look nothing in those movies makes
me laugh and I don't like emasculated
men I just don't know don't love his
movies I thought a stand-up was great
yeah but the book is like very late
doesn't really get into the movies and
he gets into the molestation scandal and
the Sunni thing hard well it's like
you're so used to like a guy like we're
going on stage and kind of like getting
around you know getting around it but he
like it's like most of the book is like
detailing we I don't see how you can
read the book and still think that did
he did it and then Mia Farrow's not
batshit crazy
and that Ronan Farrow isn't off that's
one of Ronan Farrow Ronan Farrow in the
book he's running Farrow had that
surgery to get taller where they break
your legs several times and make you
make you like six inches taller because
he once they get into politics one day
and you have to be tall to be in
politics and it's like he said that's me
doing this like it makes me a pharaoh
sound completely insane in a way that
you're like yeah I can imagine this
and like a lot of his like relationships
were kind of toxic he's very open about
he was attracted to crazy women yeah
beautiful yeah and didn't see the red
flags yeah but he gets into it in a way
that I have not seen a comic - Wow they
all kind of try to sidestep it I'd like
I'm reading this book and it's
fascinating it's interesting it's hard
to separate the art and artist isn't it
because all of his movies are so fucking
pervy it's so hard to imagine like why
like what he did with Mariel Hemingway
back in the fight she was like 16 years
old and like the kid he was like 45 in
the movie like why like age I've always
just thought it was a creep and I feel
like women
we just have this like Sixth Sense which
I know is not like something that you
know is easy to explain you know it that
having a gut is not enough for something
to happen legally but you're like that
guy's just I we just know who's fucking
gross yeah and don't it's like a sixth
sense you develop over time where you
just have to go like like his movies
creeped me out way more than you way
more than the book dudes Christie Vic's
Tina bike Barcelona it's just there's no
story he was just like I want to make a
movie where Scarlett Johansson and
Penelope Cruz fuck each other I'll
figure it out
I want to go to Spain like that's how I
feel like he makes his movies I was more
creeped out about him describing those
actresses him describing Scarlett
Johansson him described being Emma Stone
just like her like in a complementary
way but in this lake like is your wife
mad at you right now for this for what
you just said then I was about just am
talking about the scandal and Mia Farrow
it's also the way he dresses his
actresses are always so they're always
in like khaki shorts like he's just got
a very specific thing that he does where
he sort of D sexualizes them and some
physically in some ways like they don't
get to wear makeup like he has a very
specific idea of what the with how
they're it's a very controlling
aesthetic they're always in like off
like green army shorts have you noticed
this Scarlett Johansson always looks
like she just came out of like a fucking
made well sale I I've got to admit I've
only seen like like six or seven of his
movies all the same they're all exact
same story exact same thing I just I I
so much vitriol over like because I just
think his he was such a good comedian
that we think his
these are good but like you know he was
like the Dame cook of his day let's be
honest I remember seeing Vicky Cristina
Barcelona with a date and someone I was
dating at the time a long-term
relationship and it's all about like
there is no monogamy like what saw like
this yeah and I'm like walking out I'm
like I love that movie and they're
crying they're like crying and I'm like
no I loved it because I saw it with you
because everyone in that movies a
fucking idiot and I'm glad we're not
done and they were like what are you do
you get in a lot of fights in your
relationships I get into one what at the
end can I get like everything is so good
like in the beginning I'm just like so
happy and I'm a hammer and everything's
great and I'm not really and I'm there
yeah like if it's if the passions there
okay and I'm like I'm in your egg I'm in
totally and then I'm very conflicted
averse you know I don't want to
I forgive quickly and if I'm in trouble
like if someone starts crying I'm like
what kind of you to make you stop crying
yeah what can I do I'll do whatever and
sometimes afterwards I'll be like
annoyed that I did that but that's my
reaction is I make you stop crying and I
avoid complicating to forgive but that
one fight that we get into it because
we're not used to fighting it's over but
again I haven't been in a relationship
in seven years okay so because you say
we we don't fight we don't fight we
don't fight so by the time we do fight
there's no practice or there's no is no
practice and it's like it's like the
shine is off and now I guess this is
over that it's like I that's I think
it's like part of the immaturity mm-hmm
maybe just the relationships that I've
had but it's like I'm not a big fighter
people who want to fight for the sake of
fighting well now you just want to yell
and I'm not into that yes I said once we
get in like a real fight I'm just like
all right like the bloom is off the rose
yes maybe we don't break up right now
but like what on that it's the
resentment is building and the writing's
on the wall yeah what does your
therapist say about it okay like like
I've said this and just through therapy
and I'm a huge like a people super like
I don't see if they're opposed it's like
I'm I've been seeing a therapist for
seven years and I'm very into it what
put you into it getting famous like 2013
it was like I'm getting a TV show like
I've got like I'm play
she's like I got a deal with this yes I
people my family who I wanted to see see
a therapist to like we're like no I'm
not doing that dumb shit that I was like
if I can go and explain it to them what
it's like maybe that'll help them okay
and I got so much out of it that I was
like I'm gonna keep doing this
yeah but I would say I'd rather be
lonely than annoyed and I just I've
tried to force the relationship just to
be like I'm by myself all the time like
how you don't go to parties because it's
just me showing up by myself that like
just have someone to go to a party with
would would change my life like like
immensely because I would just do more
things you know I'm not like a I don't
go to parties alone I I do but I don't I
don't get invited to a lot of lean on I
mean like really think I'm gone or don't
want to do things but if I'm with
someone it softens me yeah it's like as
a date like a double date kind of thing
but but I would I would just I get so
annoyed like quarantine it's like would
you like people who are like how you
quarantine alone I'm like how will you
continue with someone because I would
lose my fucking mind right I would
murder someone correct if I to deal with
it I am fascinated by what you just said
because I feel like we might be similar
in this way is that when I don't get
invited to something I get a notice like
why don't people about what and then
when I asked they'll be like well I just
figured you were busy
like I just people don't think to invite
me to things part of its a comedy thing
we were on the road all the time that's
right you know you're in a relationship
so you're always watching movies and
then you break up and you like remind
your friends again that your friend yes
yes yes sounds like that only for like
years yes like oh I thought you were on
the road I thought you were busy yeah I
just didn't occur to me that on a Friday
night you would be around and wanted
like watch a movie with my friends it's
like I would love to like I would love
to do this dumb shit but people don't
think - I'm guilty I literally would
never think to ask you to hang out no a
lot of people don't and like I
[Laughter]
definitely was partially the meanest
thing I've ever said to someone
do you remember Dan by lack you of
course Dan by lack was once like hey
like you know me my girlfriend well I
could thinking like maybe double date
sometime like we would love to like hang
out and I go we're not really in the
market for new friends
meanest thing I've ever said this but
you didn't write like I could probably
find it you didn't write like LOL jk no
I never write that I never it will go
through times where we're like really
texting a lot especially during
quarantine and then I'm like oh this
should lead to like a hang and then I
and I think I was like oh I'm gonna go
for it want to hang out and you're like
no I'm good I mean if I if I want to
hang out I'm like yeah let's do it but
if I truly don't yeah like I've just
learned it's okay to say no and people
laugh when you do it but like not like
I'm gonna see this movie nope nope I'm
finally able to do that and I actually
think it brings you closer oddly
unfortunately there's an honesty you
don't feel like someone's like doing it
on purpose the very people you're trying
to repel you're just bonding closer to
you mm-hmm
we've texted a lot Jesus Christ I feel
like we're getting closer as we get
older I believe so I feel like we're
finally coming together what's up with
the dog I thought your eating at a dog
you tweeted that me not to get the dog
yeah I like the first two weeks of this
quarantine were the worst for me where I
because I was getting ready to do a TV
show so I was like working out five days
a week I was like in the writers room we
had like seven of the eight scripts done
we're like okay keep preparing and then
it was like okay nope this is not
happening where I kind of like I went
from not drinking at all or smoking pot
at all to being like let's go and had a
couple days in a row where I went off
and I went online I was on Twitter she's
thinking I was being funny but the next
day everyone's like you need some things
like are you okay yeah and one of the
things the first thing I was like I'm
gonna get a dog and then I was like
going off about other shit and you were
like maybe you shouldn't be getting a
dog I was like okay I know but still I
was like like literally to like everyday
for one hour a day I'm on my couch
reading I pretend I have a dog and it's
laying on my couch and I'm petting it
and I'm loving it and then for the rest
of the day I'm glad I don't have the dog
cuz I live in a small place okay this is
like an amusing house I worry if I lived
in a place like this it would take away
of my work ethic you know that I would
just be too relaxed yeah my home looks
almost like a boxing gym for writers
okay that makes sense like I need this
sort of space yeah and it's not
conducive yeah to an animal at all but
what it took me a long time to learn
this someone way smarter than me explain
it to me that actually not that I'm
saying you should get a dog I'm not
trying to pressure you but they like
small spaces because the more space they
have the more territory they think they
have to protect so they actually like
their dead animals you know it's more
like your dog is beautiful I like the
big dog kind of thing but I just like I
also look at my like my Eames chair I'm
like if this fucking thing came in and
ate my Eames chair I don't know what I
do
and your aunt liked it it's hard to buy
paper towels you know I mean like I
would be like given I had to go to a vet
you know I'm just I'm just glad that I
don't but when people when I go to
someone's house we like a socially
distant like dinner I'm so happy when
they have a dog and I truly love dogs
yes I like cats too but I'm more dog
actually not to have the box of shit
yeah house but I thought if I had it
like a backyard yeah you know I would I
would be I would have a dog in the fact
that that people did a run on shelters
we're like shelters emptied out that I'm
like okay like so that's kind of over
dog rights are up 300% because people
rescued a bunch of dogs they had no idea
what the fuck they were doing with yeah
a lot people to give them back it's like
this is too anxious yeah yeah or people
just like through a dog in that wasn't
socialized and they let their kid just
start hitting it and they're just like
dude like it's been a disaster I was
walking with a friend the other day and
there's this guys holding this like two
guys smoking a joint outside a van like
this is in like Hollywood he's got one
of those tiny little dogs you know they
look like little rowdy dogs
looks like you wouldn't be scared up
yeah yeah my friend and I walking by and
it and she had been bitten in the face
as a child so she's very scared of dogs
but this is like a tiny dog and this dog
just like out of nowhere mm-hmm just
goes after her yeah and like bites
literally her like a kill east-end in
that area yeah and it starts going nuts
and she's screaming trying to get away
and the guy the stoner guy's so shocked
that his little dog did something and
was like and finally pulls it away and
I'm like we about to go to the fucking
emergency room with like and she was
wearing ankle weights and the dog just
happened yeah and this happened or got
the ankle rape the dog got
henkle wait did she tell you that sir no
a friend of a mutual friend of ours she
was just on Instagram the other day and
she just wrote putting my way ankle
weights on and I was like Oh Riki
Lindhome wears ankle weights like I just
had never yeah that was her like that's
a way to like exercise and she was just
like it just happened to just get the
ankle weight and nothing else and they
guys for toy like like I was like that
dog must have reacted to the ankle way
interesting problem because like the guy
seems so surprised that his dog did that
at all he was like a dog like lunch at
people's dogs who routinely by people
they're just doing the same thing over
and over again expecting a different
result and they're constantly shocked
and they just have sort of like their
dog is up on a pedestal and they just
sort of have gauze over their eyes like
Mike would never do that I'm like bitch
I saw your dog do that at the dog park
for the last three weeks in a row your
dog always does this it's just like
people cannot accept that their dogs
have bad behavior and they won't just
course crack so I would not be surprised
if that happened fucking a lot dogs
don't just decide to do something
different today that they've never done
before but this sometimes you like be
pulling a leash a little bit yeah you
see someone coming in your leg that the
leash this guy didn't did he was just
like oh yeah I'm sure it happens all the
fucking time but but small dogs actually
bite way more than big dogs Chihuahuas
bite way more than pit bulls it's just
they don't leave a mark so they don't
end up being like news stories yeah
you know because they have to be have a
Napoleon complex cuz they're small I had
a friend who has one of my old roommates
had a girlfriend we've got a pitbull
sweetest thing in the world had no teeth
so it was like no danger to anyone any
so sweet but if it saw another dog they
would lose its goddamn mind
will you be walking it and all of a
sudden you're like and everyone's
staring at you and it's screaming that
I'm like I can't have this no and you
don't know until you buy a dog like I
have friends who live in houses a
beautiful house yeah and you heard dogs
barking all over the neighborhood that
I'm like how do you know until you move
in yeah what this is gonna be like
that's right that I that scares me about
getting a dog is like is this gonna be a
Barker yeah no I live in like a building
I want my neighbors hating me because my
dog is going on any dogs with prey drive
if they hear stuff why they think you
know anything in the walls air
conditioning like apartment living can
be harder for dogs with prey Drive
mm-hmm
terrier Shepherds stuff like that
Australian Shepherds everyone's buying
Australian they're very beautiful
I'm the fucker but they're heard they
get very stressed out when things aren't
organized when I lived in New York I
like to really guy wanted a Great Dane
so someone offered to drop me off like a
Great Dane puppy beautiful and like
Mastiffs I love really big war says I
was in New York and I really wanted to
mast it because people like their kind
of apartment dogs they can just take a
little space and just chill all day they
sleep all day I was like great I want to
I'm gonna get a mastiff one day I'm on
Fifth Avenue in New York City and I see
this couple this guy in this girl who
were both models like they were very
beautiful it almost like brother and
sister but not quite just enough it was
like okay like all male and female
models look like the other and they're
like they're wearing like they're like
they're dressed immaculately they're not
gonna have a black hat and they're
walking these two gorgeous Mastiffs and
I'm just like oh that's active life like
that's what I want and then one of the
Mastiffs stops in the middle of Fifth
Avenue on the sidewalk and takes the
biggest shift and the guy pulls out an
entire roll of paper towels okay so you
have not been a relationship in seven
years that's a long time this means
you're not an addict Congrats
thank you must be nice I mean I was in
constant relationships for a long time
okay and then I just like was like okay
like I thought that about you I feel
like in our 20s I was like oh he's like
a serial monogamous yeah I was right
yeah I always had someone and then I
would like almost go like almost right
away like I would leave that person for
the next one yeah and then eventually
you know you went on a couple dates with
my best friend my best friend when we
were like and actually you handled it so
well I'm not gonna put her on blast on
this but she you guys went on a couple
dates and then you called her and you
said hey I'm getting back with my ex and
you said it in like a very classy way we
should go with a broken food problem yes
that was the problem she was like he was
super into me and I was like I can't
start dating someone with a broken leg
like she's cool and I did I did get back
with my ex but we met and we're like
flirting at the table and she she got
hit by a car like before like I
I met her she had already been hit by
the car and she had this giant boot on
and these crutches and I was like you
can't start a relationship like you
can't do this that like we did go out
but I was like this is a non-starter it
had nothing to do with her as a
personality but there's no way you can
get into a relationship you asked her
out after her foot had already been
broke I know but we were like sitting
there it would be like you and me
sitting here like this you know I knew
but I did not realize how it was going
to annoy me like how it was gonna be
like I can't like we can't start this
way yeah the whole thing that I was just
like it was it was thick it was such a
turn up in a way that I can't be like
I'm not gonna like correct her or be
like this is the reason that I can't do
this but it truly was like she was a
lovely girl
but it was just it was like it was six
months of this and then we find out what
you're really like I couldn't I just
couldn't do it but I did get back
together with an ex it was such that
wasn't a lie but I remember what had
happened it was at El Cid on Sunset her
she had been hit by a car and broke her
foot she's jogging she Russ walked
that's right she was on crutches that
had a giant boot and then you asked her
out yeah we met it was like someone
else's birthday party it was her
birthday party yeah and remember Topher
Grace singing her happy birthday that's
interesting yeah but we were just
talking and I'm just like we had a
connection that I was like all right
cool and then like when we went out I
was like fuck like it's gonna take you
this long to sit down like I just I just
could not do it like what like is that
his thing
like he's into like like girls that are
broke and can't move around like what
and it's played so much into the fact
that I thought you were like this dark
guy I was like oh yeah he's into women
they're like suffering and in pain and
like incapacitated yeah horse tracks
sitting done talking I was like this is
cool like clearly you're flirting with
me like I'm into this and then like
moving around I was like I'm not gonna
work but then I remember cuz she called
me
it is very hard to end an embryonic
dating situation hmm it's easier I think
to end a monogamous relationship because
you can go well you're a fucking asshole
are you lie to me or I'm out of ending
something after a couple dates is
weirdly harder mm-hmm and it's also this
was like before ghosting like a ghosting
I don't feel like that was a thing until
recent no you couldn't do it then you
had to tell them why you were gonna stop
calling them yeah you know and no guys
ever done it elegantly it never goes
well and she called me she's like yeah
he's getting back with his ex and like
no one was mad yeah that never happens
like I was very I was respectful I
wasn't like a jerk
it wasn't like well you did this it was
like your grades yeah I know we just met
and it was like early enough we've been
on like maybe one day I think we'd like
maybe kissed
yeah there was no like I was like what
would it be like to lay down with
someone with like fucking half their leg
and and like an iron lung like I just
think it just it just it just what it
wasn't like a turn-off it was just
seeing it was on a gay I just couldn't
get my mind around I couldn't get my
mind around there's one of my best and
oldest friends and she's like everyone
just loves her like ever she's like saw
her vests in she like looks like Kate
Hudson she's super smart she was like
running production of paramount like
she's like a badass and I remember going
okay Anthony's gonna ask her her with a
broken leg is better than me fully
functioning I was like I gotta work on
my personality
cuz guys would just ask her out
incapacitated before they would ask me
out like fully able to fuck mmm I mean
like there's something really repellent
about me who said I didn't ask out a lot
of comedians like in the beginning
because it was like you know in that
beginning like when it's someone's like
let's write together should hang out and
write you know I had a couple of those
where I was like oh this is like oh now
this is weird where I'm just gonna be
professional yeah with comedians
occasionally meet a friend and you know
someone like really flirted it was like
oh this is like there's a chemistry here
obviously dated comedians before yeah
but no I've dated a few I did in the
beginning it was like it seemed like the
thing to do right now it's like the last
thing in the world
yeah I I wanted to yeah and let me ask
you something
why should people date comedians and why
shouldn't comedians date communions I
think that comedians are a little bit
like it's like it's like a writer and an
actor combined it's like that
temperamental and that insecurity that
they're always gonna be like it's not
always you sometimes it's like like I
just once had like a relationship and it
had been like a long time because I was
just like having a hard time working at
Fallon I didn't want to complain about
my job so I just like kind of closed off
oh yeah yeah and then we like shut down
that it's like you got to deal with like
you've got to do with the artistic
temperament and the schedule yes of a
comedian and comedians dating each other
is tough because and like explained us
perfectly like let's say let's say you
and I date all right we dated for a
while
okay and then we break up and then you
date Chris D'Elia
okay right now Chris D'Elia knows
everything about oh wow you know what I
mean that it's like this kind of like
it's it's that's part of the attraction
yes that you shouldn't be doing this
well so you've got to see each other all
the time or there's something that's
just like something really
self-destructive poisoning the community
by doing it and I think as you get as
you did like now it's a we're almost
like brother and sister because we've
known each other for so long right that
unless there was some like Woody Allen
moment where we're like under the
moonlight and we like have this like
epiphany wearing Woody Allen pants I'm
wearing fucking the exact shit that Emma
Stone wears in every one of his movies
just like I'm still relatable I'm so
like effortlessly flexy interesting
because I've always liked and as I sort
of get older and I'm like more able to
wrap my head around my character defects
and like how to rectify them and
course-correct them and realizing that
when I date someone who's not a comedian
I just I realize like a lot of at least
men and I hate to bring gender into it
cuz I'm sure it goes the other way I
just don't I just don't know but a lot
of men needs women to laugh at them it's
very some I'm een I'm sure everyone
needs that on some level right and when
I when something's funny
I say that's funny that's how we laugh
sometimes you know like oh that's funny
and it's like you know a mixture of
either being dismissive to try to get
you to just stop doing whatever you're
doing doesn't make me young come
durable like people trying to be funny
than our comedians it sometimes makes me
uncomfortable if it's feeling forced
right
I dated a comic one who would get so mad
at me it was like whoo like I could not
convince that I thought they were funny
right like I quit and I was like I
wouldn't be with you if I didn't think
you were funny right
but they would ask me something I go
like that's funny like try it make sure
I don't say it they could ask me about a
joke
yeah and they would go you don't say
that's what you think something's funny
you don't say that's funny you'd like
this you go you know what I mean when
you like think of a joke yes you don't
laugh you guys you it's like this
epiphany thing we kind of like stop and
like like we'd be talking and I would go
and she go what did you like I know it's
some great joke and they would like kill
them that I never did that to them even
though I'd be like that's funny like
like try it go ahead a good one right
you know like haha maybe like that's not
what you that's not i cannot fake i can
fake a lot of things i cannot fake laugh
at somebody and i realize and and and
like a couple of relationships ago i
just realized what this guy he would get
so angry at me he would get so angry
when we go to a party and i'd make
people laugh we'd get in the car and
he'd literally be like what the fuck was
that good it's like I just like I'm just
I'm programmed to try to make strangers
laughs I don't know Houston to them it's
as they act as if you like when instead
of arm wrestling everyone and one you
know what I mean like I've I know a girl
who was like I was dating a guy that I
was really into it was really cool and
he was like I'm breaking up with you
and she goes why and he goes I've got to
be the funny one and she goes but you're
not funny
she goes you don't even try to be funny
like you know whatever to see if he goes
and he goes I know but I have to be the
funny one in the relationship like I
can't have you and I was just like that
sounds fucking tragic but I but I
understand it's not a judgement and I
realized I was like oh this guy doesn't
want a girlfriend he wants a fan you
know and I'm just not a fan of your
comedy like you know and I sort of was
like and then it's only now that I'm
like I have to date a comedian like I
mean we know everyone so that'd be
impossible but I just sort of like what
like who do we date because I and I also
realize as I say this
I reduce people to their jobs you are
your job to me and that's something I
need to work on like a lot of my
girlfriends ooh this week you know who
you need an architect that's what you
need someone who's like smart it's like
you can't reduce someone to their job I
guess I have a real problem and I've
like and I've tried to find a
relationship I would love to I wouldn't
it's like I'm against them but I found
that a lot of people treat me like a
lottery ticket like a winning lottery
yeah you know it's like you're
successful you know you're not ugly
Mickey blue eyes you've got ambition is
a big thing Instagram is a fuck you is
such a giant check in the Pro column too
because such a big part of relationships
now is like okay you follow 15 porn
stars and you follow all your exes like
it's just someone not being on Instagram
it's like it takes off so many future
sort of anxieties yeah people just try
to go to like from like zero to married
with me or they just think they would
they're way too excited or not like this
is still like a first date territory you
need to chill out but they just get too
excited that it liked it but it turns me
off way more you mean these people
online um sometimes someone sometimes
like after show like at the store
somebody fan of yours but II but I
thought who aren't fans and we start
talking and then they find out what you
do you know where you've been talking to
someone than someone else walks up and
like Whitney like I yeah like then
you're like the fucking coolest yes yeah
I never assumed someone knows who I am
ever like I've made appointments for
stuff and I show up and they're like
right this way and I'm like how did you
and then I we know who you want yeah
yeah I mean and I'm like okay yeah but
yeah I just don't like that it's it
feels like a certain pressure mm-hmm
that I don't and I don't not
reciprocated yeah it's like you're way
more into me than I am into you and
maybe I could have gotten there but I
just feel your excitement and it's like
it grosses me out it's repellent but
what if it's for you Anthony not Anthony
what if it's not for the celebrity
Anthony doesn't what if it's just for
someone likes you can you some guy can
you - the warmth can you like someone
that likes you yeah I can like them by
just don't may not people want to be in
a relationship that's right like I like
to have friends uh-huh you know I could
spend time with people and I like to be
close with people and I'm
happy to like you know share secrets and
talk about things I wouldn't like that
wouldn't be public with you bye I like
being intimate I don't know problem with
intimacy it's just if I'm gonna like
have a partner mm-hmm like it's gotta be
an interesting I'm like I would need to
meet like a sculptor who like travels a
lot like someone who's got who's an
artist was their own thing going on okay
who's not like trying to get like like
like you help me get a manager I don't
need that sure no no no you can't do
that but I also think that sometimes
people like I want someone their own
thing going on as long as it's going on
at the times I don't want to see you but
not the times I do want to see you like
I found myself doing that I need someone
with a big life and dadada and then it's
like oh no you can't go to New Zealand
for six months and have a life or I need
you to be home from four to six because
I leave it so it's like I need you to
have a life on my terms
yeah like I realize like how selfish my
terms are a lot of the time but it's
interesting cuz yeah I do find myself
I'm not proud of this being slightly
repelled by someone who wants to date me
too badly yeah you know you can just
feel that energy yeah they're just too
excited yeah it's just too excited that
you're like I it yeah or like I don't
want it's it's a turn-off
yeah like yeah it might just be like a
human nature thing and not like do you
know about your attachment strategy like
do you have any kind of like at like the
attachment strategies preoccupied
dismissive you might be secure actually
which is very rare which is just like if
you're in a relationship with someone
and they travel for a week do you get
anxious or insecure no or jealous no you
don't strike me someone who gets jealous
I've never gotten jealous never in my
life like I swear to god and drives
people crazy because I always think like
that would drive me a little nuts I
always think like if you don't want if
you want to cheat on me you don't to
date me get the fuck out yes yes I don't
need this like yeah
I'm cool with you saying I'm out of here
yeah but if you'd like think that like
you're like that like those movies where
the husband wants to leave his wife and
his links she can make it so he tries to
kill her yeah kind of thing yeah and
it's like it's like she would be okay if
you got divorced like she would might
try a little bit you have to kill the
person
yeah yeah I've never felt I've never
felt jealousy and then I I know I'm
gonna have to let you go at some point I
just I feel like I never get to see the
we always ask them on the show what are
some red flags in relationships are just
people red flags being too gung-ho
smiling too much you know for no reason
something like smile so much for no
reason who like uses things someone who
uses your name too much when you meet
them because you know there's like this
tricks this is PR tricks yeah you know
hello Whitney nice to meet you when I'm
strip big fan Whitney like those kind of
things Scientology thing / complimentary
bugs me even though the executives know
like I had an exactly that was just
always make you my favorite comedian and
I was like what would you say if I
wasn't you know I mean this is like
you're like putting this on me and
making me play this game with you yes
right I had a meeting with Netflix to
market my last special and they go you
know Anthony you're special and when
this big like conference room like this
presentation ago you know yours is the
first special we've ever gotten that we
had no notes on and I go it's I'm so
honored that you'd think I would believe
you like what note did you give Chapelle
on his last special
what was it I would love to see the
notes email to Bill burr you'd love to
see that email yeah like that's like
it's one of those things that like they
think it sounds good but like I just I
see through a lot of that stuff yes yeah
that's those things just seem like red
flags to me yes
yeah like when people call their exes
crazy that's always just so unattractive
to me because it's just like well you're
gonna call me crazy when this is done
mm-hmm you know like I know what you're
doing like it's not making me more
Indian who badmouth people they used to
date total it's like I'm not yeah I once
said a friend I was like I was like this
person is so beautiful and they were
like oh I slept with so-and-so and like
this movie star and they were not good
and I was like well you guess what's
never gonna happen yeah guess what's
never going to happen because all my
head would be like I better fucking like
I better show cuz it's like it's PR yes
you know 100% someone being rude to a
waiter some being rude like in general
like to anyone is is is a red flag to me
like completely unacceptable yeah any
sort of like racial slur to be funny
people like oh you're comedian like okay
so three black guys yeah nope nope nope
we're not doing this year the fuck
trying to be funny is red flag
you know they don't be funny with me Wow
you don't to do that interesting you
know or like trying to appear too smart
like that just like trying to yes yes
yes yes be relaxed yes I do think though
if I may your bachelors are like you
give a healthy amount or like you give
just enough you know that I can see of
myself certainly 10 years ago being like
you're giving 10 I'm gonna give 90 you
know what I mean or like I think silence
is really triggers people I think it
brings out people's inner child and
makes people start sort of like trying
to figure out like what you want and
what's gonna get you to smile and what's
gonna get you know are you mad or what
you know like they probably project a
lot onto you and project their shit onto
you and then progress to what worked as
a child yeah that's what I guess
certainly possible and I can see a lot
of like what do you think about you mad
what are you mad about fucking every one
of my favorite quotes ever they asked I
forget the writers name but they asked a
writer using her there to go what do you
think is wrong with the world
mm-hmm he goes I am and I was like fuck
yeah like that is like my philosophy in
a nutshell that like if so if the advice
doesn't work out I'm not like this
person wasn't good enough it's like it's
like we didn't work out yeah but I'm the
problem a lot of the time I'm just very
comfortable with my flaws you know okay
we're really gonna go but last thing I'm
gonna ask you for real this time is
what's the best advice that you've
gotten if I don't ask this question
people lose their shit the best advice
I'd the advice for me the best advice
that I've gotten just in general
honestly the best advice is when and
this is in common it's a strictly comedy
okay but when a comedian gives you
advice they're only trying to make you
more like them isn't that everyone all
the time with ever it doesn't apply to
everything I think so I didn't applies
across the board but it's like if
someone's like what can you tell me I'm
like I'll say go see the movie comedian
with Jerry Seinfeld that taught me a lot
yeah write as much as you can get on
stage as much as you can those are the
only pieces of advice you can give
someone that's because if you're like
hey take the mic out of the stand no
we're like hey don't
laugh at your own jokes it's like Who am
I to say that like that could be end up
becoming right you're a thing they're
like if I had taken any of the advice
people would given me
yeah the first ten years I did this
that's right I would not be here but I
think like Doug Stanhope said that he
was like someone was asked giving him it
he wasn't giving someone advice that had
asked him for advice and someone Kaplan
was like hey man
when you give someone a comic advice
you're just trying to make them more
like you that is actually to me that is
resonating so deeply because my new
philosophy is don't ask advice for
people that don't have the thing you
want that you're asking about don't ask
single people advice about relationships
don't ask married people advice about
when you're single you know what I mean
don't ask non comedians advice about
comedy you know I mean like that is just
like my new because I used to spend so
much time taking advice from people who
were like not in relationships about
relationships I was like what am I
asking you your might your mess you know
so that's just so interesting that that
really is probably what people are doing
myself included when I give advice yeah
it's like give me big stuff and a
positive attitude but if you like give
this specific advice yeah you can maybe
been saying this is what works for me
right you know try this kind of thing
but yeah I try to give like I either
don't give advice or very very vague
advice because you know if you're like
you know red or blue then I can maybe
you know oh yeah it's like it's a good
number one or number two then me back
you know I can give you my opinion
uh-huh but but yeah I try to stay out of
it that's wild I don't want ever stop
talking to you Anthony time we should do
this more often I would love to I always
end these very awkwardly um Caligula
fire in the maternity word love and
light
am I missing thoughts and prayers
thoughts and prayers do you imagine we
call in a special love and light what's
my album called we put out albums around
the same time can I tell you something I
did black out like two years of my life
I believe that if you tell me I'll know
it but hold on okay can I tell you
something I didn't remember my album
name until just now
I'm trying to remember I can
to the cover okay pink like like I'm
cute
it's not called it's not gonna feel it
it's really fucking and it's I I am so
embarrassed about pretty much the first
couple years I'm so you know and this is
gonna sound bad and but kind of similar
to yours when especially female
comedians come up to me and they're like
how do I get this and I'm just like dude
don't fucking put anything on camera
until you've been doing this for eight
years you did put out an album too early
I know you put now I'm like two years
before I did and I like waited a long
time just like oh wow like this is like
oh great and luckily albums that like
aren't what they like now it's special
thing people don't know my first album
was called Shakespeare okay and if I
wonder what's such a fucking great title
thank you I wonder what my career would
be like if I had waited a couple years
and that had been a special ah instead
of because that was seven years in the
making and then Caligula was my first
special was like three two and a half
because I had to like take my career
took off and it was like go go go yeah
that I wonder if they had all been
specials and no albums like because it's
like even Caligula my floor special on
Comedy Central yeah people don't know I
did it people only know about thoughts
and prayers and firing the maternity
ward because of Netflix right then I'm
like oh if I had just been like and you
can't you can't let that get in your
head yeah drive you crazy it's like if I
just like if I it's if you and I had
started a year earlier we would have
been a part of a different class of
comedians you know what I mean like I
mean a graduating class it was like I
felt like I was like a year below BJ
Novak and Denman's
what I mean but if we'd start a little
earlier and it's like you can't let that
get into your head yeah but I guys
sometimes wonder buttocks I think some
of my jokes on Shakespeare some of the
best jokes I've ever written well see
that's the other thing I'm thinking
about it I'm like I would say if like
20% of the jokes I did on my first album
which I don't even know where the fuck
it is or if it's anything I mean
sometimes people will say like I heard
you on raw dog or something and I'll be
like what and it's that like someone
else owns the rights to I don't even
know where the fuck it is some like you
know criminal managers me and um and I'm
like if I just had 20% of those jokes
put on the first special and made them
better my first special would it matter
it's so true mm-hmm you know but I do
sorry my
I was twitching no I think that because
in the beginning I was like I am like
sassy and have to be like Lao I thought
being like loud would like neuter me or
something and shocking but for shocking
say you know like I just look at that I
think it was so embarrassing it was
called emotional ninja emotion yes now
is such a great like parody of a
comedians call their specials like men
and women are different according but um
but yeah I I when girls come up to me
especially now where it's like women you
know people think women are funny
finally and people girls will come up to
me like how come I'm not getting spots
at the store and how come I'm not
getting especially I'm like dude
you're not good yet I did it I got stuff
to early I'm here to tell you just wait
an extra couple years and be good I
promise you when people would always say
like oh like women know how it's like
not fair for women why do women have a
tough time in comedy it's like listen
I'm friends with all of like the best
women in combat yet like I can sit to
myself like Friends of the men we're
like cool and it's like and they're all
exceptional people and then work their
fucking asses off and they're funny as
hell like you just have to be great like
it's not got nothing to do with being a
woman like cutlets how many clubs are
like do you know any women we could put
in this lineup because we're getting
killed like whenever we post a lineup
online that there are opportunities and
I think a lot of women get opportunities
too early and they and they just like
and they take them even though they
should not and just get better but the
ones I know are just fucking killers yes
well that's what drives me nuts because
everything how come they're not more
women at the comment store cuz they're
selling out 40 shows in San Francisco
Ali's busy I mean it's just sort of like
cuz they're on tour selling out theaters
they're not here and they have fucking
families or whatever they're they're so
successful they're choosing just natasha
chooses to stay home in a couple days a
week do you know what I mean so it's
like it just it gets real this
conversation gets really frustrating cuz
it's also a lot of people a lot of women
choose not to do stand-up you know
that's the other thing they're you know
so it's like and also a place like the
store like you have to be going every
night and earn that spot you know and
the way that the world is just sort of
designed it's just it's not how shit
hand out and I guess to me it's like
nothing is worse for female comedians
than female comedians going up and
sucking because everyone sucks in the
first five years
everyone everyone when a when a when a
male comic bombs they're just go that
guy bombed and you move on if a girl
bombs we all bombed oh when I'm on the
road like doing clubs I have like I have
a female oh I always bring female
openers oh yeah because I find that a
lot of you Robin Tran with you a lot
right
I do Largo with me but I've never taken
her on that road road I've recent friend
but the ones I'm like I would take them
out and I would ask for female MC to
know nice and but the female MC would
always be terrible yeah you know I mean
it's like MCS are always terrible right
man la Petite it and they'd be like all
right your next comedian she's and you
would hear the audience go like two in a
row and then my then my opener comes up
and kills and they're like okay great
you know they're like the MC is going to
get bad out of what it's not some
because she's female yeah when I first
started the Comedy Store the intros were
always like are you guys ready for a
lady I always loved staying who's ready
for a lady it just sounded so funny to
say like I everytime seed I'm like this
is my favorite part
[Music]
people start going I'm going to the
bathroom like people start feeding their
meters but yeah it's just it's just so
to me I always feel kind of guilty
saying it but like when girls come up to
me they're like I've been doing comedy
for six months like how come I can't get
a special make cuz you're just not good
yet yeah it's not because you're a girl
you know but yeah anyway I like to end
these super awkwardly what's going on
with your podcast you know yet
we're negotiating right now my thing my
contract become essential ran up and
we're getting that buck out of there
doing like this why don't you fucking do
it in D style so I don't want a half
keep all the back end like I thought it
was hilarious that you built a studio in
your own home before you started doing
it what if you hated it like what if you
didn't like doing podcasts I keep that
built all this shit and then I like hate
but I'm saying what I would
what would have made me hate it would be
driving to a fucking student that's I
don't like driving I like podcasts once
I'm there when it's my friends but I
don't like fucking driving there and
driving on when I signed the deal is
because I could walk to the studio two
blocks and now we found out with my
producers we can do it in my house they
just bring the equipment and so we're
just gonna do it like that yeah so it's
like wherever but but it should be back
soon hopefully yeah I should I should be
I should have chosen the place hopefully
by either at the end of the day or early
next week and then we'll see you know
they gotta sell ads and stuff soon it's
called the Jeselnik and Rosenthal vanity
project junior VP it's me my best friend
and it's like well we just it's it's
basically like imagine what my best
friend is like and what I'm like with
like you and I are very close very good
friends very close we have a it's this
is a different conversation that would
be if I was being interviewed by someone
that's right but imagine my best friend
in the world like a what I'm like with
him and so it's just I think that's
important because I would imagine people
are kind of trepidatious to like kind of
come at you too hard but someone who's
known you for a long time is probably
not scared of you less he's like a
sports guy right yeah he works for the
NFL yeah he works for the NFL Network
what's gonna happen with that you have
any intel with the NFL Network I mean
what ball coming back they release the
schedule and like the NFL's got so much
money like they're safer than other
things but it's been like there's a
hiring freeze you know like I don't
think is getting raise anytime soon but
he's under contract for a couple years
so hopefully by the time he's facing
anything that I'm just curious because
it's once Sports is back in music is
back we're back you know yes
right so I keep I don't think we're
coming back before music and I don't
think we're coming back for sports I'm
wondering I think the Comedy Store will
be like we'll open the main room every
other table kind of thing I mean the
problem with that and sorry to get so
granular on this I mean I think this is
probably interesting to people is that
they they won't make money you know like
no one makes money on half capacity
that's what everyone keeps going look
let's open clubs at half capacity it's
like well that's just that you know and
I was at coffee B and my mom's in a
nursing home
and all she wanted was coffee so I could
happen to go into a fucking coffee bean
right which in California right now is
like pretty wild thing to do I am a mask
it said you can't come in without a mask
right so I go in no service with a mask
I've got gloves the whole thing scarf i
order my drink I'm like six feet from
her she backs up three feet I move
forward to put the credit card and back
up she makes the drink I move six feet
away
she puts the drink on the bar pushes it
over backs up like the logistics in the
physical gymnastics just to take a cup
from this woman like when will we be
back in a place emotionally where a
waitress can give you a drink in a dark
room and you just take it and put it in
your mouth don't even that but you don't
think about you're not thinking the
whole time of like what nine other
people have touched this drink and now
it's gonna go in my mouth in the dark
while I'm exhaling for two hours with a
bunch of strangers literally like you
know so not only when will comedy open
again but when will the environment be
conducive to comedy I think people are
gonna want to come back earlier than you
would think they would but get me in the
dark laughing with your mouth open
doesn't seem like the most like like the
biggest thing and like there's a chance
I don't ever just stand up again there's
a chance just you yeah because you're
just I've done I've put out for hours
I've got 15 minutes of the next one then
it's not like enough that I'm like I've
got to finish this like I couldn't and
if it comes back like kind of half-assed
like I got to enjoy like the best of the
best and I don't have to that if other
things if other opportunities come up
yeah then who knows and I don't think
that's gonna happen right like I can but
I could I think I'll take off longer
than most people because even when
things come back people start going on
the road yeah then use the competition
for venues is gonna be so insane it's
like do I want to get his fights over
this no I might just wait until that's
done for a year and then come out and
hopefully yeah but if I come up with a
great bit then I'm like I've got to get
this I think things are I mean and look
I'm not trying to force you to get on
Instagram but it's like there also is
this iteration of like you know I mean
when I did my last enough hook special
they were like hey people put I don't
know if I'm allowed to say this really
people pretty much watch the first
so could you just you know people like
opening with their closers and shit now
like I put a robot in the end of mine
because I was just like if people cuz
kind of what happened
you know Hannah Gatsby special like you
know which was obviously very good
people would go like it was amazing it
was brilliant and was like oh my god in
did you see the end everyone was like
I'm gonna like I'll get to it
I've had people be like I've seen the
first 15 minutes you're special it's so
funny that comics and I'm like why did
you say that to me Bert Bert Kreischer I
swear to God goes dude I saw the first I
only saw the first joke but the first
joke of your special is one of the
funniest jokes I've ever heard and I go
so funny that you turned it off
immediately and like my new special
opens like I'm like write about it like
I don't have any preamble it's like
here's the first joke I hate this it's
not it's not even walking on stage it's
not like like it's just I'm just like
now love it but for people to say that
and I'm like when comics I'm like I
don't expect you to watch and like my
spec Natasha Leggero was like oh I
haven't seen it yet and I'm like why
would you like why would you watch it
yeah you know I've seen yours because we
did research you were gonna be on my TV
show and we like did research and watch
all your stuff yeah fantastic by the way
I expected more robot I expected like
the whole thing to be robot it was just
no no because I felt like again I always
have in the back of my head what are
comets gonna think of this and I was
like everyone's you like oh she's a
fucking ventriloquist now and her fuck
she's a prop comic she's the new Jeff
Dunn I'm like I just knew what comics
what I would say if a comedian did that
oh I would make fun of them and I was
just like I got I got like three or four
laughs out of her and that's it because
when I saw that when I saw you doing
like the social media I was like oh
that's so fucking good like that's so
fucking good I can't wait to see what
she does with it and I was like I was
just at the just at the end yeah I have
to sit through 50 minutes of her comedy
it was great special special but but I
just I was like fucking dog like I know
this dogs coming yeah well I mean that's
what I realised that for people that
have only seen the social media and not
the special would probably be
dramatically disappointed whereas the
people who just watched the special
would probably be delighted to see the
robot but I didn't want to lean on her
too much and I didn't want it to feel
like cheap or anything I was like this
special has to be able to stand on its
own but it was completely made out of
insecurity that people were not going to
finish this bad
and like you know oh that's so smart
totally out of insecurity so the people
even if they only saw the first
half-hour they go to a party and you see
the fucking robot and they're like what
robot and they went back and finished it
it was totally realized that was the
reason that's right oh that's great I
did it because I was like I didn't want
to have special that people started I
want to have a special people actually
finished and that flips I get people are
finishing you're special like that was
the goal you know so but I do think
specials will get shorter at some point
oh yeah I do then we're gonna get a
point where it's like half hour so we'll
go back to half hours we'll go to
fifteen minutes because it's like now
like the idea of the hour was you're on
the road and you're giving people an
hour but like watching an hour it takes
an hour of year to build an hour and
that model was built before there was
Twitter and fifty late-night talk shows
and memes in gifts like most random
people in Tampa have already gotten to
the joke with a meme yeah but you make
so much more money on the road that's
then you do for your special and no
one's gonna pay to see you do half an
hour no no I think the the road would
still be you're coming to see an hour
yeah but I'm shooting a half hour and
you can see a half hour a year instead
of an hour every three years I think of
my specials as a novel yeah and like if
you can't finish the novel that's okay
like not everyone's a reader love that
but I like that really mean to me it's
like yeah I'm not like Nate they tried
to get me to do a half hour when they
were like trying to pitch it to people
now you're out of your fucking mind
yeah like an hour to go back I know in
the 15 minutes they were like people
only watch the first 15 minutes of a
special yeah let's get worse comics you
get them to do 15 minutes and then like
oh that didn't work for some reason it's
like yeah motherfucker cuz you got
people no one's ever heard of a no one
wants to see do it like any minutes or
bad comics doesn't evil one exactly
sorry I love talking shit with you after
I did my special this is you know you
guys know that my self-esteem is often
hanging by a thread
it's it's where I give myself a
compliment but Jay Leno called me after
my fuck I mean trouble anyway he called
me afterwards and he just was like thank
you so you know he's very into the
structure of jokes he's like you're JPM
was great like your jokes per minute
like were light were what I'm just I've
never heard in a mayor
Rickon say jokes per minute like
overseas they're all very jokes per
minute and I'm like oh like you can't
think of it like that and like no if you
look at like George Carlin and these
people there Joe there was laughs per
minute oh it was last minute adjustment
okay
oh interesting maybe and maybe maybe
that's what he said I'm completing them
but he was very much like there's I
don't like fat yeah I feel like you're
very surgical oh I oh I cut all the fat
I like I just like no unnecessary words
no the connective tissue has to be there
but I also don't like segues and I and
like two specials ago I went I'm only
gonna construct this so that there's no
segways which is gonna help me have a
theme to it should feel like one
conversation and not like here's my
facebook joke and here's my airport joke
and here's my religion joke and speaking
of religion my mom's religious here's my
joke about my parents like I was like
just pick a theme yeah for each special
so that you never need segues and if you
need a segue cut the joke that was sort
of like my rule and Jay was like thank
you for not having segues first of all
and also thank you for not doing your
first eight minutes on the city you're
taping your special cuz nobody knows
where you're taping it I did that when I
did mine last one in New York and I come
out and I do all that and I cut it yeah
well of course so I come out and I'm
like thank you very much like blah blah
blah of a joke about the city and I say
something else I make fun of the opener
yeah and then it was like now I'm like
and then it starts with the now I love
that like it's like do it all like I
ain't know what the audience wants it
but when you're at home it's like Katt
Williams talking about Jacksonville for
fuckin 20 minutes dude we don't know
you're in Jacksonville like we don't
care like we don't know when this was
shot like we don't know anything about
this it drives me nuts it's like my
other thing about the theater porn when
people like spend all this time shooting
the theater and no one's like oh my god
look at the moldings they're like tip
fucking make me laugh I'm on a date I'm
trying to make this grow fuck me like
why am I looking at all these shots that
were just designed to make other comics
jealous like what is this yeah and the
last thing I'm gonna say is um cuz you
don't put like little sketches before
you're no I feel like I always I felt
like I wasn't cool for the longest side
because I was like everyone's likes 200
you wanted to like a bit in the
beginning where you're like getting
ready and I was like
no am I supposed to be doing a bit like
in the green room I couldn't even do a
afterwards thing because they were like
well let's shoot like after you come off
stage let's like shoot you coming off
stage you know we'll have it like for
the end I was like okay I just like
don't tell me about it like just shoot
it and I think this is my HBO special I
came off stage we looked the footage I
look so sad and so disappointed I
realize in that moment like do comics
come off stage yes awesome
no never like I've never heard of it
you're like you walk off me like alright
that's over like but I'll get a good
move for you
so my first special caligula on Comedy
Central I taped to I taped two shows
they both go great with the first one
I'm nervous and I'm like killing but
I've got this like thin sheen of sweat
on my face did the first show is
unusable so afterwards I'm like and like
I almost I know I can't blow it like if
you only get one shot you're gonna kill
it but if you get to first one's gonna
be a little worse we're on this last
special I made sure mentally I prepared
for years I like meditated on it to make
the first show the better one wow that I
killed so hard in the first show that I
walked off and I hugged my manager and I
was like I finally fucking did it I was
like I'm trying to go dick around in the
second show and then they go Mulaney and
John Mulaney and Nick Kroll in the
audience and I'm like well now I'm gonna
give us a show and then afterwards the
director comes back and I'm like first
show we're using that right and he goes
no we got way better coverage in the
second show so we're using that and I'm
like thank God I didn't fuck around you
know but so with like they almost didn't
matter that I did better in the in the
first show but in Caligula the first
shows unusable second show I come out
and I'm totally dry I kill and we go to
watch it in the editing bedding bag and
I'm wearing a black sport coat and a
black like button-down shirt underneath
it and the collar was sticking out and
they didn't stop me to tell me that this
is happening and I lose my goddamn eye
I'm like not just that it's that like
that but like everyone had to have seen
this and they were like don't stop
you're gonna fuck up his flow and he's
gonna start sweating and it was like no
I would have made a joke and I would
have been totally it would probably
helped me but it took the whole show up
my collars out and it's black on black
so it's not that bad but I was like so
mad that I made the producer pay for it
himself and so in the end credits
sequence it's me getting but I'm just
sitting at my normal clothes
like 10 minutes mr. Jessel not gonna go
thank you and I get in front come here
can I put my shirt on and then I put my
jacket on and they go Anthony ready to
go I go almost and I take the collar out
and I go and I walk out and on I am to
be trivia it's like it looks like he
made a mistake but at the end it shows
that he meant to do that that I'm
fucking like loved that night no it was
like a weeks later I was editing so I
was so much to wrap your head around it
and yeah it's it's I hate that I so much
funnier that way yeah so it's so good
baby so fuck you buddy I know my Comedy
Central special I was wearing like a
tight top and my belly's hanging out the
entire thing and I just was like ah
fuckers like this I'm not this came--
I'm not the belly comedian I don't want
to show my belly no one fucking told me
they just thought that was like my look
I look like a whore alright I love you
we could do this forever but you need to
stop I have to pee so bad me too me too
Anthony Jeselnik guys what a treat love
you you can't find him on Instagram good
luck
don't write elephants by E
[Music]
[Applause]